GOOD MORNING THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WILL COME TO
ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO THE COVET
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHO WILL TALK ABOUT
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN CHILD
WELFARE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE. EACH TIME
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT ANY BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON ME TOO WHEN
YOU'RE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE- IS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-5489 ONCE
AGAIN. 844-291-5489 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO THREE FIVE
FIVE THREE FOUR THREE ONCE AGAIN. TWO THREE FIVE FIVE THREE FOUR
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE STATE
SENATE WEBSITE FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL BE HEARING ALL
OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. PLEASE KNOW THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING AND HEARING. PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S BEING DISRUPTIVE WILL BE
REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHAT EVERY
EFFORT HAS MADE TO BEAT. OUT TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND THE
HEARING PROCESS. AND CONDUCT A
HEARING IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENCE ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. WE WILL NOW BEGIN
TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
COMMITTEE- DOES PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S INFORMATION HEARING. THE
HEARING WILL BE ON THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN CHILD
WELFARE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MY STAFF WHO HAS WORKED REALLY
HARD TO PUT THIS TOGETHER. THE
PANELISTS WHO ARE JOINING US
HERE TODAY ROM DIFFERENT PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA. AND ALL THOSE WHO
ARE ABLE TO JOIN US REMOTELY. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
SASANA SKINNER AND WE'RE WAITING
FOR A FEW OTHERS THAT MAY JOIN
US LATER TODAY FOR MAKING THE
TRIP HERE TODAY. WE WILL BE
HEARING FROMEXPERT PANEL IS
WORKING TO RACK IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM N. OR WITH
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO
WILL DISCUSS HOW. THESE TWO
INTERSECT. AND THE FIRST PANEL
WE WILL HEAR FROM EXPERTS WHO
WILL BE DISCUSSING THE LEGAL
FRAMEWORK OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
DEPENDENCY COURT. IDENTIFY SOME
OF THE GAPS CURRENTLY VISIBLE
WHEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED. AND THE SECOND PANEL
WILL FOCUS ON WHAT IS POSSIBLE.
IN WAYS WE CAN IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN VICTIMS AND
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. WE WILL WRAP UP THIS
HEARING WITH THE PRESENTATION
FROM UCLA PROFESSOR CENTER. FOR
STRAIGHTENING CHILDREN AND
FAMILY WE'RE GONNA BE GOING OVER
A RECENT REPORT AND ITS
FINDINGS. I WOULD LIKE TO NOW
OPEN UP THE DICE FOR OPENING
REMARKS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
SKINNER IF YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
REMARKS YOU MAY DO SO NOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIR RUBIO AND
I'M REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF. YOUR
ORGANIZING THIS TODAY BECAUSE-
THESE ISSUES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
AND UNFORTUNATELY I THINK ALL OF
US HAVE MONITORED THE FACT THAT
DURING THE PANDEMIC. INCIDENTS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WERE ON THE
RICE AND OBVIOUSLY THE- THIS
WHOLE EXPERIENCE OF HAVING OUR
LIVES SO DISTRACTED WITH
SHUTDOWNS AND NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL OR WORK HAS PUT PRESSURE.
ON EVERYONE AND SO FOR THE CHILL
OUT FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE HERE
UNDER THE PRESSURE AND THEN
MAYBE IN A HOUSEHOLD WHERE THERE
IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE GREAT AND YET
WE ALSO KNOW THAT. I'M NOT NOT.
OFTEN OR NOT THE NORM BUT- OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN CAN SOMETIMES NOT HAVE
PLACEMENTS THAT REALLY. DO THE
BEST FOR THEM AND SO WE WANT TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ADDRESSING CHILD WELFARE AND
DOING THE BEST FOR ALL PARTIES
CONCERNED SIR I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SETTING THIS UP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR SKINNER- YOU KNOW AS SHE
STATED IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE FOCUS ON THE WHOLE
PICTURE- I KNOW I'VE BEEN A
STRONG ADVOCATE AS WELL AS
SENATOR SKIN ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND- PUSHING POLICIES.
AND CHILDREN AS WELL BUT NOW WE
WANT TO SEE HOW WE CAN
STRENGTHEN. POLICIES TO HELP
THOSE CAUGHT IN LIMBO AND
CHILDREN HAVE TO BE IN THE
CENTER OF THIS CONVERSATION SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE PANELISTS
THAT ARE GOING TO BRING US.
INFORMATION BUT ALSO SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS I LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT- BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL FREE NUMBER. 844-291-5489 AND ENTER THE
ACCESS CODE TWO THREE FIVE FIVE
THREE FOUR THREE TO BE ADDED TO
THE WAITING LIST AT THIS TIME.
R. NOW LET'S- GO TO OUR FIRST
PRESENTER- WHICH I'M EXCITED TO
HEAR FROM ANYA EMERSON WITH THE
FAMILY VIOLENCE A PILOT PROJECT
AN ORGANIZATION WHICH IS
DEDICATED TO HELPING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND THEIR
CHILDREN APPEAL DANGEROUS TRIAL
COURT DECISIONS. ON THEIR BEHALF
FOR FREE I WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUR FIRST PRESENTER MISTER
EMERSON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS
RUBIO AND SENATOR SKINNER IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE AND TO BE
PRESENTING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
MY NAME IS ON THE HORIZON I'M AN
ATTORNEY ADMITTED IN BOTH
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK. I
CURRENTLY HAVE MY OWN SOLO LAW
PRACTICE AFTER YEARS
SPECIALISING IN FAMILY LAW AND
DEPENDENCY IN THOSE STATES.
HOWEVER I AM HERE TODAY
TESTIFYING IN MY CAPACITY AS A
MEMBER OF THE DEPENDENCY
ADVISORY PANEL. OF THE FAMILY
VIOLENCE HELLO PROJECT. AND I
WANT TO ADDRESS THREE THINGS IN
MY TESTIMONY TODAY. THE FIRST IS
THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO GIVE A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW. OF WHAT I
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. NO MORE
COMPLICATED. I'M THAT MANY
PEOPLE THINK THE SECOND IS ALL
EXPLAIN WHAT MY ORGANIZATION
DOES THE FAMILY VIOLENCE A PILOT
PROJECT AND THIRD OF ALL ADDRESS
SOME REAL ISSUES THAT WE SEE IN
THE CURRENT DEPENDENCY SYSTEM IN
CHILD WELFARE. SO TO BEGIN WITH-
I DON'T THINK ANYONE AT THIS
HEARING NEEDS TO BE TOLD THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NOT A HUGE
PROBLEM ONE IN FOUR WOMEN WILL
EXPERIENCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
THEIR LIFETIMES ONE IN SEVEN MEN
AND ONE IN THREE WOMEN EVERY DAY
IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
MURDERED BY THEIR INTIMATE
PARTNERS. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALSO
HAS VERY SERIOUS SEVERE EFFECTS
ON CHILDREN WHICH I WILL NOT GO
INTO BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
LEADERS ANALYSTS WELL- BUT WHAT
IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IT'S MORE
COMPLICATED THAN VIOLENCE- MANY. PEOPLE THINK OF IT AS A WOMAN
WITH A BLACK. BUT IT'S MORE THAN
IT'S SYSTEM HOW AND CONTROL. BUT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CAN OCCUR IN
ANY RELATIONSHIP NO MATTER
PERSON'S GENDER RACE CLASS OR
TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP. WE MOST
ABUSERS ARE MEN AND MOST VICTIMS
ARE OR SURVIVORS ARE WOMEN AT
WHICH MEANS I WILL USE THAT MALE
PRONOUN FOR ABUSE AND THAT
FEMALE PRONOUN FOR SURVIVOR BUT
THAT IS NOT BY NO MEANS NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE. AT ITS HEART
THE MASTER VIOLENCE IS ABOUT
POWER AND CONTROL BY THE VIEWS
ARE OVER THE VICTOR AND THIS CAN
TAKE MANY FORMS IT CAN BE
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE- STRANGULATION
IS PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS
BECAUSE THAT'S OFTEN AN
INDICATOR OF FUTURE LEGALITY.
RECKLESS DRIVING AND BRANDISHING
FIREARMS ARE REALLY VERY
DANGEROUS AS WELL A MOTIONAL
ABUSE CALLING THE VICTIMS
DEROGATORY NAMES TELL THEM
NOTHING SHE CAN DO IS EVER RIGHT
THE FOOD SHE COOKED IS TERRIBLE
THE HOUSE IS A MAX. FINANCIAL
ABUSE I'M TAKING A PAYCHECK AWAY
PROHIBITING THEM FROM REQUIRED
FROM WORKING OR REQUIRING
ADDICTIONS WORK RUINING THE
VICTIM'S CREDIT TAKING OUT
CREDIT CARDS IN HER NAME
SLASHING THE TIRES SO SHE CAN'T
GET TO WORK. GIVING A BREAKDOWN
AND ALLOWANCE OR NO MONEY AT ALL
A RECURRING RECEIPTS FOR ALL
PURCHASES ARE THREATENING
EMPLOYMENT TAKING WAY PASSWORDS
TO BANK ACCOUNTS THOSE ARE ALL
VERY COMMON SEXUAL ABUSE. RAPE
OR REQUIRING A VICTIM SHOE
ACCIDENT SEXUAL ACTS SHE'S NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH. OF COURSE A
BIG TIME TO SEND AN ABUSER
PHOTOGRAPHS OR VIDEOS OF A
SEXUAL NATURE AND THEN USING
THOSE LATER AS BLACKMAIL. OR
ANOTHER OR PUBLISHING. DO YOU
THAT YOU OUR REALLY OR FIGURES
WORK. PRECEPTS TO EITHER PREVENT
A THEM FROM LEAVING OR TO
REINFORCE AND USER OF. AND JENNA
ROLE YOU USE TELLING THE THAT
GOOD WITH DO AT OR Y. OR N. L.
RELATIONS. THREATENING TO REVEAL
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR PREFERRED
GENDER. LEGAL AND THIS MAY COME
UP LATER IN THIS HEARING I USED
FOR GOVERNMENTAL AUTHORITIES
DATA. AND USERS WILL OFTEN CALL
THE POLICE ON THE VICTIM.
THEY'LL CALL CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES ON THE VICTIM GET A
VICTIM OF VICTIM FROM HOUSING.
HEY MIKE TRYING GET A VICTIM
DEPORTED BY CALLING IMMIGRATION
. MEDICAL ABUSE- INCLUDING
CONTRACEPTIVE ABUSE REQUIRE A
BIG DOWN TO OBTAIN PERMISSION TO
OBTAIN MEDICAL CARE OR
PREVENTING. FROM OBTAINING
MEDICAL CARE OR SABOTAGING OR
FORCING CONTRACEPTIVE USE. OF
SOCIAL ISOLATION CUTTING THE
VICTIM OFF FROM FAMILY AND
FRIENDS LITERALLY PREVENTING
VICTIMS FROM LEAVING THE HOUSE
TAKING AWAY CAR KEYS HOUSE KEYS
CELLPHONES. AND TECHNOLOGICAL
ABUSE TRACKING THEM AT ALL TIMES
GPS TRACKERS CELLPHONES
MONITORING EMAIL COMMUNICATION-
REQUIRING SHE HAND OVER ALL
PASSWORDS AND FINALLY ABUSE OF
CHILDREN OR CATS WHICH IS OFTEN
ANOTHER INDICATOR VERY SEVERE
ABUSE I THINK I MAY NOT LEAVE AN
ABUSER FOR FEAR OF WHAT HE WILL
DO CHILDREN ARE PACKS A BIG
MISTAKE BECAUSE SHE BELIEVES
THAT. ALTERNATELY SAFER. NO
VISIBLE- VIOLENCE THAT'S OFTEN
THE MOST VISIBLE FORM OF ABUSE.
VICTIMS OFTEN REPORT THAT IT'S
THE OTHER TYPES OF ISSUES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY HARDER TO OVERCOME.
A MOTIONAL ABUSE CAN BE VERY
PSYCHOLOGICALLY DAMAGING. AND
THEN SIMPLE THINGS LIKE BAD
CREDIT FOR LOST EMPLOYMENT OR A
RAT. FALSE REPORTS OF POLICE
THAT CAN RESULT IN CRIMINAL
RECORDS DEPORTATIONS THE LOSS OF
CHILDREN IF CVS GETS INVOLVED.
THOSE ARE. THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
CANNOT BE RECTIFIED. I'M I
SHOULD SAY THAT IT IS CERTAINLY
TRUE THAT VIOLENCE IS VERY
IMPORTANT IT CAN LEAD TO DEATH
IT DOES LEAD TO DEATH. IN
PARTICULAR WHEN WOMEN ARE
PREGNANT OR HAVE NEWBORN
CHILDREN THAT INCREASES LEGALITY
RIGHT IT'S A PARTICULARLY
DANGEROUS TIME FOR VICTIMS. I'M
ON THE ONE HAND JUST BECAUSE
THERE IS SOME VIOLENCE IN A
RELATIONSHIP IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP. HAS TO MATCH THE
PILOTS YOU REALLY HAVE TO LOOK
AT. THIS PATTERN OF POWER AND
CONTROL AND USUALLY IF THIS IS A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATIONSHIP
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOCIAL
ISOLATION THERE'S GOING TO BE
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE THERE'S
GOING TO BE FINANCIAL ABUSE.
THERE'S GOING TO BE MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS NOT JUST
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE AT THE SAME
TIME NOT ALL ABUSERS USE
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE. OFTEN EITHER
THE THREAT OF VIOLENCE- OR THE
USE OF THE OTHER TACTICS I JUST
MENTIONED. IS ENTIRELY
SUFFICIENT TO KEEP. HIM
INTIMIDATED AND CONTROLLED AND
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE. THE BEES OR
SOMETHING DOESN'T NEED TO RESORT
TO- FINALLY BATTERS TEND TO.
WELL I'M OFTEN A BATTERY MIGHT
BE WELL EDUCATED SMART PUT
TOGETHER IMPOLITE VICTIMS MAY
PRESENT VERY POORLY. YOU'RE VERY
EMOTIONAL MAY NOT BE CAPABLE OF
INTERACTING WELL WITH AUTHORITY
FIGURES MAY HAVE TRAUMA
RESPONSES AND COULD EVEN HAVE
ABOUT SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS
IN RESPONSE TO TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE ABUSE. OF THE QUESTIONS
WHY DON'T MAKE THEM SWEET- THE
SHORT ANSWER IS A LOT OF TO
LEAVE. HART AND PARTLY THIS GOES
TO THE CYCLE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THERE IS A CYCLE. OFTEN
THERE'S INTERPRETER IT WAS THEN
AND HE'S EARNED IT DOWN THERE'S
A BUILD UP OF STRESS. THERE'S A
TRIGGER OR RELEASE. STRESS
RESULTING IN AN INCIDENT
WETHERBY VIOLENCE OR NOT. AND
THEN WE'LL BE A HONEYMOON. AND
THESE CYCLES CAN OCCUR WITH ANY
FREQUENCY ONE TODAY ONCE YOU'RE
ONCE A MONTH. VICTIMS ALSO OFTEN
STAY BECAUSE OF THAT HONEYMOON
PERIOD BECAUSE THEY WANT THE
MUSIC TO CHANGE BECAUSE HE IS
THE FATHER OF THEIR CHILDREN.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME OFTEN STAY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO OTHER
CHOICE. AT THIS POINT THEY MIGHT
HAVE NO FAMILY NO FRIENDS NO
MONEY NO CAR NO HOUSE IN YOUR
JOB. THERE'S NO WAY FOR THEM TO
LEAVE. AND THEN FINALLY. MAY
STAY BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE. IT IS
TRULY SAY FOR THEM TO. IF THEY
STAY HERE KILL HER YOU WILL KILL
HER IN THE TWO- SORRY SHE LEAVES
HE WILL KILL CHILDREN CHILDREN
IF SHE STAYS SHE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO AT LEAST DIRECT HIS VIOLENCE
TOWARDS HER. RATHER THAN THE
CHILDREN OR MAKE ME BE ABLE TO
PLACATE OR MODERATE VIOLENCE IN
OTHER WAYS. AS A FINAL NOTE
SEPARATING FROM AN END USER IS
THE MOST INTERESTING PROJECT.
THAT IS WHEN EVERYONE GOES ON
EVEN MOST DOWNS TRYING TO LEAVE
MULTIPLE TIMES BEFORE THEIR
ALTERNATELY SUCCESSFUL. IN
LEADING END USER. THE DOMINANT
TO THE SECOND PART OF MY
PRESENTATION WHICH IS WHAT IS
THE FAMILY ABOUT HOW THE
PROJECT. IT'S KNOWN AS
AFTERSHOCKS YOUR SHORT AND IT'S
A NONPROFIT LEGAL ORGANIZATION
BASED IN OAKLAND. THAT SERVES
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND RECENTLY
EXPANDED TO WASHINGTON STATE.
ITS PRIMARY FOCUS IS ON FAMILY
LAW WITH A SECONDARY FOCUS ON
DEPENDENCY BUT IT'S A GOAL IS TO
END TO THE INTERGENERATIONAL
SILENT CYCLE OF MY- SPECIFICALLY
. WORKING WITH AND IMPROVING OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM. BOTH OF THE TRIAL
COURT LEVEL THAT MEANS FAMILY
COURT AND DEPENDENCY COURT IN AT
THE APPELLATE LEVEL WHICH MEANS
ASKING THE COURT OF APPEAL IN
CALIFORNIA TO STEP IN AND EITHER
AFFIRM OR REVERSE TRIAL COURT
DECISIONS IN ORDER TO HELP
FURTHER PROTECT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS. IT'S A PRETTY
NEW ORGANIZATION WAS FOUNDED IN
TWENTY TWELVE BY TWO UC BERKELEY
LAW STUDENTS. AND THE WHOLE IDEA
BEHIND IT IS THAT CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IS ONE OF
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
LEGISLATURES IN THE WORLD WE
HAVE SOME REALLY GOOD LAWS ON
THE BOOKS TO PROTECT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS. BUT THEY ARE
NOT BEING ENFORCED IN TRIAL
COURT. NOT ALL. BUT SOME OF THEM
AND SO THAT WAS FOUNDED TO BE
LIKE HEY THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME.
ORGANIZATION HERE TO TRY AND
ENCOURAGE TRIAL COURT JUDGES TO
ACTUALLY APPLY THESE LAWS AND TO
APPLY THEM IN THE RIGHT WAY
LATER THEY JUST SET YOUR
INTENDED TO PROTECT. AND
SOMETIMES THAT MEANS APPEALING
THOSE DECISIONS. AND GETTING THE
COURT OF APPEAL TO TELL TRIAL
JUDGES HATE YOU GOT SOMETHING
WRONG. OR SOMETIMES IN CASES
THIS HEY YOU GOT SOMETHING RIGHT
ESPECIALLY WHEN AN ABUSER
APPEALS. A TRIAL COURT DECISION
THAT WENT AGAINST HIM. IN TERMS
OF DEPENDENCY THAT WILL STEP IN
WILL FILE AMICUS BRIEFS AMICUS.
IN CERTAIN- DEPENDENCY APPEALS
AND WE WILL ALSO REQUEST PUBLIC
. UNPUBLISHED ORDER THE PEOPLE'S
CASES THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
REMOVE DEPENDENCY CASE LAW COURT
WILL BETTER PROTECT VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SO NOW I'M I
DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH TIME BUT
I'M NOT SURE AND SHE FINALLY
WHAT ARE YOU KNOW WE'RE DOES
AFFECT. WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF CHILD WELFARE AND
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE CHILDREN KEPT WITH
NON OFFENDING SURVIVOR PARENTS
CHILDREN SHOULD NOT BE
PHYSICALLY REMOVED FROM VICTIM
KAREN UNLESS IT IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY CHILDREN WHO HAVE
WITNESSED OR EXPERIENCED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN THE HOME
HAVE ALREADY UNDERGONE A LOT OF
. AND REMOVING THEM FROM THE
PROTECTIVE PARENTS THE ONLY
PARENT THAT HAS STOOD UP FOR
THEM AND HELP THEM. IS A MOTHER
OR FATHER IS DOING ADDITIONAL
HARM ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT THEY
WENT THROUGH BY EXPERIENCING
THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. HOW DOES
THIS COME UP. WHERE DO WE SEE
THIS INTERESTING VIOLENCE CASES.
WE TYPICALLY SEE THAT'S WHERE
THE NON OFFENDING VICTIM PARENT
IS ALLEGED TO HAVE FAILED TO
PROTECT THE CHILD. DEPENDENCY
COURT WILL COME IN. AND TAKE
JURISDICTION OVER CHILD BASED ON
CERTAIN- YOU KNOW STATUTES THE
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE.
AND ONE OF THEM IS IF YOU FAILED
TO PROTECT A CHILD FROM- YOU
KNOW DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR FROM
ANOTHER PERSON OR A STUDENT.
AND- OFTEN ALTERNATELY CHILDREN
ARE REMOVED FROM THE VICTIM'S
PARENTS BECAUSE THE CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY ALLEGES THAT THE
JUDGE AGREES THAT THE VICTIM'S
PARENTS. CHECK THE CHILD FROM
WITNESSING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SO
WHAT WHAT. THIS DOESN'T COMPORT
WITH WHAT IS BEST FOR CHILDREN
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD
NOT BE JURISDICTION OVER
VICTIM'S PARENTS FOR FAILURE TO
PROTECT FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN AND OF ITSELF. TELL YOUR TO
PROTECT FROM ACTUAL PHYSICAL
ABUSE OR SEXUAL ABUSE IS ANOTHER
MATTER AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
SHOULD STILL BE IN THE LAW BUT
THIS FELT THE CURRENT PRACTICE
OF REMOVING PARENTS FROM PROJECT
PROMOTES A WHOLE HOST HAS A
WHOLE HOST OF BACKGROUNDS ARTS.
I'M OFTEN NUMBER ONE IT OFTEN
PROMOTES AN INCORRECT
UNDERSTANDING OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THAT'S LIMITED TO
PHYSICAL. SOCIAL WORKER
TYPICALLY DON'T SEE ALL OF THE
OTHER TACTICS THAT I MENTIONED
ABOUT THEIR ONLY RESPONDING TO
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE- PUNISHES THE
VICTIM HER ACT. IT'S BASED ON
THE INCORRECT ASSUMPTION THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A MUTUAL OF
ACTS THAT BOTH PARTIES ARE
EQUALLY RESPONSIBLE AND THEY
CONTROL THE KIND. THE VICTIM
PARENT MAY. HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO PROTECT THE CHILD AND NOW
SHE'S ALLEGED TO HAVE FAILED TO
PROTECT THE CHILD. THE VICTIM
PARENT MAY INDEED HAVE PROTECTED
THE CHILD BY SAY TAKING AN
ABUSER'S VIOLENCE AND DIRECTING
THEM TO HER AND NOT THE CHILD.
AND SHE'S TO HAVE FAILED THE
CHILD. IT CURRENT FOR REPORTING
ABUSE AND THIS IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT IF A VICTIM PARENT
CALLS THE POLICE TO REPORT THE
VIOLENCE THE POLICE OFTEN WILL
CROSS REFER TO CBS THEN THERE'S
A DANGER OF DEPENDENCIES IS
INSTITUTED A SURVIVOR IS GOING
TO BE SEPARATED FROM HER
CHILDREN AND SHE MAY BE
SEPARATED EVEN AT THE SAME TIME
WHEN THE PROSECUTION'S REQUIRING
HER TO TESTIFY. I'M USERS NO
THAT'S OKAY AND THEY WILL TELL
VICTIM DON'T POLICE YOU CALL
THE POLICE THE SECOND REPUBLICAN
BC YES WE OUT HERE AND YOUR KIDS
WILL BE TAKEN AWAY. AND SO THIS
IS A REAL BIG CONSIDERATION- IT
WHAT. WE MEANS HAVING THIS
FAILURE TO PROTECT CASE LAW IN
HERE STATUTE IT DISSUADES
VICTIMS FROM COMING FORWARD
REPORTING YES- AND THEN WHEN THE
VICTIM DOESN'T REPORT THE ABUSE
ONE OF THEM DOESN'T CALL THE
POLICE ON SOMEONE ELSE'S STATUS.
THE VICTIM IS STILL SEPARATED
FROM THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE
EMPLOYEES DO GET CALLED IN AND
SHE'S TOLD SHE SHOULD HAVE
CALLED THE POLICE. IT'S A CATCH
TWENTY TWO AND THERE'S NO WAY
FOR A SURVIVOR TO ACT THAT DOES. NOT PUT THEM AT RISK.
ULTIMATELY I THINK. THIS IS A
POINT OFF LOSSES TO PROTECT
PUBLISHES THE CHILDREN FOR THE
ACTS OF THE ABUSE- YOU KNOW GIVE
A CHILD IS. AND I ALREADY SAID
THIS BEFORE BUT I'M GONNA SAY IT
AGAIN. IT'S PUNISHING THE
CHILDREN THE CHILD IS REMOVED
FROM THE ONLY PROTECTED
CURRENTLY KNOWN AND PLACED IN A
FOSTER. IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. IT THAT'S NOT RIGHT IT'S
NOT THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD IT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
DAMAGING. AND THEN FINALLY- YOUR
PROTECTORS DICTION WHEN
DEPENDENCY COURTS COME IN
THEY'RE REALLY ONLY SUPPOSED TO
REMOVE A CHILD OR EVEN ASSUME
JURISDICTION OVER CHILD IF THERE
IS A CURRENT RISK OF HARM TO THE
CHILD. HELLO OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND FAMILY BUT
THE VICTIM BY THE TIME IT GETS
TO DEPENDENCY COURT HAS SLAPPED.
A SEPARATE IT MAYBE SHE'S GOT A
RESTRAINING ORDER MAYBE SHE'S IN
A SHELTER MAYBE SHE HASN'T SEEN
THE ABUSER FOR FOUR MONTHS-
XCERRA. AND YET THE DEPENDENCY
COURT STILL ASSUMES JURISDICTION
OVER THAT CHILD STILL SAYS THERE
IS A CURRENT RISK OF HEART WHEN
THE VICTIMS LIKE. I SEPARATED I
DID EVERYTHING YOU ASKED ME TO
DO I AM NOW IN A SHELTER I HAVE
A RESTRAINING ORDER OPERATING
WITH THE PROSECUTION AND YOU ARE
STILL TELLING ME. THAT I FAILED
TO PROTECT MY CHILD. IT IS NOT
EXACT. YEAH CONVINCE VICTIMS TO
TRUST YOU KNOW GOVERNMENTAL
AUTHORITIES OR OR- OR AGENCIES
AND A FUTURE SO. IF WE ARE GOING
TO MAINTAIN. THIS FAILURE TO.
PROTECT LANGUAGE AS IT IS
CURRENTLY. NOW IN THE LAW THERE
NEEDS TO BE MORE OF AN EMPHASIS
ON CURRENT RISK THE CHILD JUST
BECAUSE THERE IS PAST HARM. DOES
NOT MEAN THAT THERE WILL BE
FUTURE CAR- AND ALSO I HAVE SEEN
AT BOTH JUDGES AND CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES. ONCE IS A WELL
DOCUMENTED FACT AND YOUR
RELATIONSHIPS TO ARGUE THAT-
WELL THE VICTIMS ONLY BEEN
SEPARATED TWO MONTHS. SHE'S
GONNA GO BACK TO HIM SO
THEREFORE WE HAVE TO STEP IN AND
WE HAVE TO ASSUME JURISDICTION
OR REMOVE THE CHILD. BUT BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT SITE IS
BROKEN. IT'S NOT THE RIGHT WAY
OF THINKING ABOUT IT- THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OTHER WAYS A CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY CANTOR INFORMALLY
SUPERVISOR FAMILY. I AM AT
TAKING JURISDICTION OR REMOVING
A CHILD FROM A PARENT SHOULD BE
THE LAST SHOULD BE DRASTIC.
MEASURES THAT ARE ONLY TAKEN
UNDER EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES- I
HAVE PLENTY OF HER COMMENTS BUT
MY TIME IS UP. B. TO TAKE
QUESTIONS- I WILL NOTE THAT I
WILL HAVE TO SIGN OFF AT ELEVEN
AM AND DID YOU AT NEXT PANELISTS
WILL BE DISCUSSING IN MUCH MORE
DETAIL ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS WITH
THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH ON
YOUR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- YOU
TOUCHED ON A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
ARE. REALLY SIGNIFICANT- FIRST
OF POWER AND CONTROL THAT YOU
DISCUSSED- I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT EVERY SINGLE TIME WHEN I
DO TALK TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT. EVERYTHING
THAT YOU ADDRESS IN TERMS OF
POWER AND CONTROL AND HOW WE
HAVE THIS MISCONCEPTION OF WHAT
IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND A LOT
OF TIMES IT'S- ODD THE POWER
CONTROL THAT HAPPENS BEFORE THE
PHYSICAL ASSAULT BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE EITHER. CHOOSING WHO AT
THE FRIENDS ARE ISOLATING PEOPLE
FROM THEIR FROM THEIR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND SO I ALWAYS LIKE TO
TELL PARENTS WHO THEY'RE
LISTENING WE USED TO ASK
TEENAGERS HAVE YOU BEEN
ASSAULTED. HOW'S YOUR BOYFRIEND
OR SIGNIFICANT OTHER ASSAULTED
YOU BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
CHANGE THE WAY WE ADDRESS THAT
AND ALSO ASK IS YOUR- BOYFRIEND
OR GIRLFRIEND COURSING YOU ARE
THEY CHOOSING YOUR FRIENDS FOR
YOU ARE THEY TAKING YOUR PHONES
AWAY FROM YOU SO I'D LIKE TO
JUST. PUT THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THE
COERCION HAPPENS WAY BEFORE THE
PHYSICAL ASSAULT THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SHARED AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT. WE HAVE TO CHANGE OUR
MINDSET WHAT IS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU BROUGHT FAILURE TO
PROTECT WHICH IS AN ISSUE THAT
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO. TO DELVE
INTO AND RESOLVE I THINK THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE. OB TRAUMATIZING A
VICTIM TWICE IN THE FIRST BY THE
ASSAULT SECOND BY REMOVING A
CHILD THAT SHOULD BE WITH THE
NON ABUSIVE PARENT AND SO WE
DEFINITELY TO LOOK INTOIT. I
WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO- SENATOR
SKINNER ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU- I'M GONNA DECIDE WHEN
QUESTION I OBVIOUSLY I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN THIS THE. THE
POINT YOU MADE ON THE ABOUT THE
FAILURE TO PROTECT AND HOW THAT
HURTS THE CHILDREN PUNISHES THE
CHILDREN AND THE VICTIM SO
DEFINITELY WE'LL TALK MORE WITH
THAT MY CHAIR ABOUT HOW WE MIGHT
PURSUE TRYING TO FIX THAT BUT-
THE OTHER LINE I WANTED TO JUST
ASK NOW IT'S NOT THE FOCUS OF
THE HEARING PER SE BUT T'S- IT
BEARS ON ALL OF THIS. IS OUR OUR
LAWS NOW ADEQUATE FOR DEALING
WITH THIS COERCIVE ASPECT IS
CONTROLLING ASPECT OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. ON SENATOR RUBIO FOR
EXAMPLE HAD A BILL. THAT I
WORKED WITH HER- AND I THINK IT
WAS MEAN COLLECTOR BUT- WHERE WE
RECOGNIZED THAT. THERE WAS A
LACK OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT WITHIN
OUR STATE PENAL CODE AND WITH
OBVIOUSLY WITHIN THE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR. THE TYPE OF
CONTROL OVER THE TYPE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT ISN'T
THAT DOESN'T LEAVE PHYSICAL
SCARS BUT IS THAT CONTROLLING
DEBT IS VERY EXTRAORDINARILY
DAMAGING. AND SO  WONDERED IF
YOU FELT THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATELY- FIXED OUR PENAL CODE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT PART. OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I THANK YOU
SENATOR CENTERED SKINNER FOR
THAT QUESTION I AM GOING TO HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU BECAUSE THAT
IS. AN EXCELLENT QUESTION AND- I
NEED TO LOOK INTO IT FURTHER I
DIDN'T PROVIDE I DIDN'T REVIEW
THAT RIGHT BEFORE THE HEARING
THE STORIES. I WILL BOTH THE
JOURNAL INTEREST IN THAT FOR THE
FUTURE AND I THINK THAT WHAT WE-
ARE YOU KNOW I MEAN LOOK YOU
CAN'T IT'S- IT ABUSERS. WHATEVER
THE- THERE'S LOTS OF TOOLS THEY
CAN USE BUT I THINK WHAT WITH.
THINGS LIKE SOCIAL MEDIA NOW THE
ABILITY TO MORE EASILY. FIVE
SURVEIL YOUR- YOUR VICTIM THE
PERSON YOU ARE TRYING TO
CONTROL. THAT THERE'S- THERE CAN
BE THIS THAT MANY MORE FORMS OF
THAT CONTROLLING COERCIVE
BEHAVIOUR. SO I THINK AND YET IT
IS. EASILY IF NOT EVEN MORE
DAMAGING THAN PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
. I WILL SAY THAT TECHNOLOGICAL
ABUSE AS YOU TOUCHED ON IS
RISING- ESPECIALLY AS THE
YOUNGER GENERATION USE
TECHNOLOGY MORE AND MORE. AND IT
IS SOMETHING THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COURTS ARE
GENERALLY ILL EQUIPPED TO DEAL
WITH- WHETHER THAT'S BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES COMPUTER FORENSICS TO
TRACE SAY IT DAMAGING POST BACK
TO AN END USER'S COMPUTER- OR-
SIMPLY SOME TECHNOLOGICAL KNOW
HOW. IT'S OFTEN BEYOND MOST
JUDGES ABUSERS AND STARED SORRY
MOST JUDGES AND POLICE OFFICERS
TO SIMPLY SIMPLY LACK THE
RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE AND SO
I THINK THE FIRST THING THAT
CAME TO MY MIND WHEN I HEARD
YOUR QUESTION IS. IT'S ALMOST-
THE LAWS WE HAVE ON THE BOOK
RIGHT NOW. CERTAINLY CAN BE
IMPROVED BUT IT'S ON THE GROUND
ENFORCEMENT HOW ARE THEY GONNA
GET ENFORCED WHO IS GOING TO
ENFORCE THAT- AND I THINK THAT
OFTEN JUDGES AND POLICE OFFICERS
AND YU JUST NEED TO GET JUST
LOOK THE OTHER WAY THEY CAN'T
DEAL WITH THAT THEY CAN DEAL
WITH A BLACK EYE. THEY CANNOT
DEAL WITH THE VICTIM SAYING HE
POSTED IT- YOU KNOW NAKED PHOTOS
HE TOOK WITHOUT MY CONSENT TO
GRINDER WHICH HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME. AND IT'S- THE- AN END.
COME HOME. OXFORD PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND. AM I THINK THAT TODAY
THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND AND I'M
TALKING TO POLICE OFFICERS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS. THEY KNOW THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS BAD AND
THAT IS THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE
FORTY YEARS AGO WE WERE NOT
THERE. BUT THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS NOT JUST PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE SAYS THERE'S AN
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
COMPONENT. AND THEN THERE'S A
RESOURCE COMPONENT- SAY THERE IS
TERRIBLE TECHNOLOGICAL ABUSE WHO
WHO'S GOING TO PROSECUTE.
BATTERY WAS GONNA LOOK INTO THAT
. SO I WILL BACK TO SPECIFIC
REMARKS DOES THAT MY TAKE. THIS
IS BECAUSE A LINE OF INQUIRY
THAT WE CAN PURSUE WE DO NOT
HAVE TO SPEND MORE TIME TODAY
BECAUSE OUR HEARING IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT BUT I THINK THAT- WE-
IN THE COURSE OF THE BILL THAT.
THE SENATOR KERRY SENATOR RUBIO
CHAIR. WE DISCOVERED WE MET
WOMEN WHO EVEN AFTER SO THEY
WERE IN THIS CASE IT WAS ONE WHO
WAS SUBJECTED TO PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE. BUT WHO THEN WAS ABLE
TO HAVE HER ABUSER PROSECUTED
FOR THE PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
COMPLETELY REMOVED HERSELF AND
HER CHILD FROM THAT. BUT THEN
THAT ABUSER LATER WAS ABLE TO.
WIPE OUT THIS WOMAN'S CREDIT
HISTORY. AND PLANT THINGS
THROUGH HACKING AND SUCH THAT
WERE DISPARAGING TOWARD HER
WHICH THEN AFFECTED HER CAREER
AFFECTED HER ENTIRE PLANET I
MEAN LOOK BASICALLY CREATED.
LONG TERM DISASTROUS RESULTS. M.
WHICH WE NEVER WERE ABLE TO BE
I'M NOT ABLE TO BE BUT RATHER
WERE NOT EVER PROSECUTED. SO THE
REPERCUSSIONS REMAIN GREATER
THAN THE INITIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
BUT ANYWAY IT'S A LINE OF AREA
THAT WE'VE OBVIOUSLY TO PURSUE
SEPARATELY. BUT ANY INFORMATION
WOULD BE HELPFUL AND I THINK THE
EDUCATION. PROBABLY IS THE
IMPORTANT PART. THE ONE THING I
WAS IN A SPOT THAT IS WHEN-
YOU'RE HAPPY WHEN I FAMILY AND
THAT. SISTER AND- THE VICTIM IS
TRYING TO GO THROUGH YOUR
REUNIFICATION TO TRY GET HER TO
BACK. WHAT YOU OFTEN SEE IS THAT
BATTERIES WILL SABOTAGE THAT
PROCESS FOR INSTANCE IF SHE
NEEDS TO ESTABLISH INDEPENDENT
HOUSING AND A JOB TO GET HER
KIDS BACK OR AT LEAST TO BE
STABLE ENOUGH TO DO ALL THE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
COURTS REQUIRING HER. IF HER
CREDIT IS RUINED AND SHE GETS
HER FIRED FROM THE JOB THAT CAN
REALLY SABOTAGED VICTIMS-
ATTEMPTS TO GET THE CHILD BACK
SO IT ACTUALLY DOES COME UP
INDEPENDENCY. IN MORE OFTEN THAN
YOU WOULD THINK. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT I JUST WANT TO ADD
TO ITS REAL QUICKLYSO THE BILL
THAT I PASS WITH THE HELP OF
FASTENERS SKINNER WAS S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY ONE WHICH DEFINES
COURSE OF CONTROL- AND I DO KNOW
BASED ON. ALL THE MESSAGES I
RECEIVED FROM VICTIMS-
CONSISTENTLY IT'S STILL A
CHALLENGE TO HAVE COURTS
RECOGNIZES UNDERSTAND IT AND SO
THE EDUCATION PIECE IS IMPORTANT
AND THE ENFORCEMENT PIECE IS
ALSO IMPORTANT- I WANT TO
WELCOME OUR COLLEAGUE AND
SENATOR ANNIKA YOU KNOW WHO HAS
JUST JOINED US. WELCOME THANK
YOU- FOR YOUR TESTIMONY BUT NOW
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO- SENATOR
COVER YOU FOR ANY COMMENTS FOR
OPENING REMARKS. WELL I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR VERY
MUCH FOR- SCHEDULING THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING- REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE INFORMAL
DATA INDICATES THAT- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. IT HAS BEEN ON THE
RISE DURING THE- CURRENT VIRUS.
PANDEMIC AND- AND SO WE NEED TO
BE PREPARED- TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
ASSISTANCE TO. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE. INTERESTED IN LEAVING
AN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP SO THAT
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES AND SO
THAT OUR COMMUNITY HAS THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO THINK VERY MUCH OF THE CHAIR
FOR. THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS AREA. THANK
YOU- NEXT HOUR WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT PANELIST JULIE
MCCORMICK WITH THE CHILDREN LOST
CENTER. SHE'S A SENIOR POLICY
ATTORNEY AT CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA. SHE IS
ALSO A PRACTICING FAMILY LAW FOR
HAS BEEN PRACTICING FAMILY LAW
FOR OVER A DECADE BOTH IN THE
PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT SECTOR.
JULIE HAS ALSO WORKED ON POLICY
AND LEGISLATION IMPACTING
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU CHERRY BO AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS FOR SHEDDING
LIGHT ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AND
FOR PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO SPEAK TO YOU- FIRST
LET ME EXPLAIN CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER CALIFORNIA. THE
ORGANIZATION I WORK FOR
REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND
PLASTER. FOSTER CARE SYSTEMS- I
WAS LIKE HE'S CARRYING A TRAY
FOR THIS ORGANIZATION FOR ABOUT
SEVEN YEARS SO DID DIRECT
REPRESENTATION FOR HUNDREDS OF
CHILDREN IN YEARS- PRIOR TO THAT
I WAS. PRACTICING FAMILY LAW-
AND WORKED- FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
FOCUSED ON TEENS AND DATING
VIOLENCE- THE EDUCATION AND
LEGAL REPRESENTATION OF THOSE
YEARS- AND SO WE WANT TO TALK TO
J. I APPRECIATE ON YA FOR LAYING
SOME GROUNDWORK AND TALKING A
BIT ABOUT DEPENDENCY. AND THE
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE MY- TELLS ME TODAY IS
GOING TO BE FOCUSED ON- I GET A
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF DEPENDENCY
COURT SYSTEM. THE IMPACT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ON CHILDREN
AND THE THINGS THAT WE SEE WHEN
THESE CHILDREN USE COME INTO.
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM I THEN
WANTED- LOOK AT THE CHILD
WELFARE INTERVENTIONS IMPACT ON
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND SORT
OF THE THINGS THAT- WE SEE AS
PROBLEMS AND- WHAT WE BELIEVE
ARE WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
POSSIBLE. SOLUTIONS GOING
FORWARD SO VERY BRIEFLY-
DEPENDENCY COURT THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM- YOU'LL HEAR WE
HAVE A PARENT'S COUNCIL COMING
ON AFTER ME THEY WILL GET MORE
INTO THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK A
LITTLE MORE INTO THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE. BUT THE- READ
THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM HE SAYS
COME INTO OUR SYSTEM ONE OR FOR
ALL THE VIEWS OR NEGLECT- COMES
IN AND THAT CALL CAN COME FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT A MEDICAL
PROVIDER A TEACHER. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE COUNSELOR A SHELTER- AS
YOU MENTIONED IT CAN COME FROM
DEBUTS ARE THEMSELVES- BOARD CAN
COME- THE VICTIM- AND I THINK
WHAT WE SEE IS- WHEN SOMEONE IS
SEEKING OUT HOW. THAT IS SOMEHOW
THAT'S WHY THEY FOUND BUYING
THEM SO AND- IN A STORE. SO
THEY'VE GONE TO ACCOUNTS OR
THEY'VE GONE TO A SHELTER
SEEKING HELP AND THEN A REFERRAL
IS MADE. TO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THOSE REFERRALS ARE THEN
INVESTIGATED AND IF THEY ARE
SUBSTANTIATED CASES FILED WITH
ARTWORK WITH THE DEPENDENCY
COURT- AND UNDER CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW. THE STATE WILL THEN
GET AN ATTORNEY THE PARENT HAS
AN ATTORNEY AND THE CHILD HAS A
RIGHT TO AN ATTORNEY AND THAT'S
WHAT THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
DOES WE REPRESENT. THE CHILD
ENSURING THAT THEIR VOICE IS
HEARD ALSO INSURING THAT THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
ARE BEING MET DURING THE TIME
THEY FALL UNDER OUR SYSTEM- ONE
OF THE ISSUES WE HAVE SEEN AS
REALLY IS A LACK OF GOOD SOLID
DATA. AS IT RELATES TO THE
INTERSECTION OF CHILD ABUSE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. ON YOU
BRIEFLY MENTIONED THAT THERE'S
THIS WEEK HOW THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY- AND THAT IS OUR
NEGLECT STATUTE. NOW WHEN HE'S
COMES IN UNDER THAT STATUTE IT'S
VERY BROAD IT CAN FALL UNDER
GENERAL NEGLECT IT CAN BE A
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE- THAT THE
PARENT IS EXPERIENCING IT COULD
BE SUBSTANCE ABUSE. AND FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE A LARGE NUMBER OF
THOSE CASES DO COME AND DUE TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND WHEN THEY
COME IN WHAT THE LAUNCH OF THE
PAGE IS THAT THE SYSTEM IS GOING
TO PROVIDE REGIONAL. SERVICES TO
THE PARENTS. RIGHT TO PREVENT
REMOVE. HOWEVER BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF RESOURCE.OR JUST.
BETWEEN THE CHURCH WELFARE IN
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COMMUNITY
WE SEE THAT MANY OF THESE CASES
LEAD TO THE CHILDREN BEING
REMOVED- SO WHAT WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS. WHAT WE CAN HEAR A LOT
TODAY IS WHAT THE SYSTEM IS
DOING WRONG- AND THAT IT IS
PUNITIVE TO PARENTS WHICH WE DO
NOT DISAGREE WITH. OUR WE LIKE
TO FIRST ESTABLISH THAT THERE
CAN BE AN ONGOING REST. TO A
CHILD IN A HOME WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. SO WE'VE SEEN THERE
ARE STUDIES THE IMPACT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ON CHILDREN.
THERE'S POTENTIAL RISKS THE
PHYSICAL REST. STUDY SHOWING
HOMES WHERE VIOLENCE BETWEEN
PARENTS A CURSE PARTNERS FIRST.
CHART INCREASED RISK OF BEING
ABUSE. THEY ALSO CAN EXPERIENCE
PHYSICAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING GENERALIZED ANXIETY.
SLEEPLESSNESS NIGHTMARES
DIFFICULTY CONCENTRATING. HIGH
ACTIVITY LEVELS INCREASED
AGGRESSION- INCREASED ANXIETY
ABOUT BEING SEPARATED FROM A
PARENT OR EVEN INTENSE WORRY
ABOUT THEIR SAFETY OR THE SAFETY
OF THE PARENT THAT IS BEING
ABUSED- WE'VE ALSO SEEN THAT
THERE CAN BE. LONG TERM PHYSICAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS- AND THEN
BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS THAT DEVELOP
INTO ADOLESCENCE. AND STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT CHILDREN THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN THE HOME- CAN HAVE A
HIGHER INCIDENCE OF DELINQUENCY
INVOLVEMENT THEY CAN BE 75274%
MORE LIKELY. TO COMMIT A VIOLENT
CRIME- 50% MORE LIKELY TO ABUSE
DRUGS OR ALCOHOL. TWO TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO REPEAT THE CYCLE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- AND I THINK
IT'S TIME YEAH MENTION THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR GOAL IS
TO STOP THE INTERGENERATIONAL
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE SO. WE DO SEE
A GREAT CONCERN FOR CHILDREN
THAT ARE- WITNESSING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IF THEY ARE LIKELY TO
REPEAT THAT CYCLE. THEY ALSO CAN
EXPERIENCE EMOTIONAL
DIFFICULTIES. IN ADULTHOOD WE'VE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN OPPRESSION
ANXIETY DISORDER AND POST STRESS
DISORDER. SO CLEARLY THERE ARE
UNDOUBTEDLY SITUATIONS OR
INNOVATE INTERVENTION IS NEEDED
GIVEN ALL THESE INCREASED RISKS.
HOWEVER WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THE
SYSTEM RESPONSE CURRENTLY IS
HUGELY DETRIMENTAL TO FAMILIES-
THERE'S SORT OF A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL AND I BELIEVE THE PANEL
ITSELF TO ME BRIAN'S GOING TO
ADDRESS THAT MORE. BITE- REALLY
IN THE SYSTEM BY WHICH CAN BE
CAUSED BY A RANGE OF ISSUES AND
WHAT I MEAN- YOU KNOW FOCUSED ON
THE POWER CONTROL OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE DO SEE WE ALSO SEE
FAMILIES- THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
POVERTY. OR HOMELESSNESS OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR MENTAL HEALTH
AND INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES IT'S SORT OF A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL REMOVE THE CHILD FROM
THE HARM. AND NOT GIVING THE
FAMILY THE SUPPORT NEEDED TO
EITHER ADDRESS THEIR UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS WHETHER THAT BE SUPPORT
WITH HOUSING OR MENTAL HEALTH OR
GETTING THEM INTO IT- SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT PROGRAM OR
ADDRESSING UNDERLYING TRAUMA AND
RELATIONSHIP ISSUES- SO THESE
INTERTWINED ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS AND POVERTY. REALLY
PAT GREAT PART AND A LOT OF THE
CASES THAT WE SEE COME BEFORE-
OUR COURTS- AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE THING THAT WE WANTED TO
FOCUS ON IS THE MANY THE MYRIAD
OF REASONS. THAT A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASE COULD COME IN AND
HOW RIGHT NOW THE SUPPORTS ARE
NOT BEING PROVIDED- WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN AS I MENTIONED THERE'S A
REASONABLE SERVICE REQUIREMENT-
THE LAW REQUIRES THAT BEFORE
FAMILY IS SEPARATED. THEY SHOULD
BE PROVIDED SERVICES TO
ELIMINATE THE RISK- OFTENTIMES
THERE ARE GREAT BARRIER SO WHEN
A- VICTIM IS BEING TOLD THAT
THEY'RE FAILING TO PROTECT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT REMOVED
HIMSELF FROM THE SITUATION. BUT
AS WE KNOW HOUSING CAN BE A HUGE
BARRIER I'M TELLING- EVERYONE IN
CHILE AS WELL AS- BABY ALL
THAT'S AVAILABLE IS A SHELTER
THEY CAN ONLY KEEP OUR HER
CHILDREN THERE FOR A FEW WEEKS.
OR ARE THERE SOME FINANCIAL
BARRIERS AND WHERE THE JOB IS-
LANGUAGE BARRIERS WE SEE WE SEE
IMMIGRATION BARRIERS. AND THE
CURRENT PROCESS REALLY TAKES
AWAY THE VICTIM'S POWER- THEY'RE
EXTREMELY PRESCRIPTIVE PLANS
THAT IT'S LIKE A GUY IN THIS ONE
SIZE FITS ALL. THAT THIS IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING OKAY YOU NEED
TO IMMEDIATELY LEAVE THE ABUSER
LEAVE EVERYTHING THAT YOU'LL NOW
WITHOUT REALLY ADDRESSING WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE AND WHAT SUPPORT
CAN BE GIVEN TO THEM- ONE
EXAMPLE WE OFTEN ENCOUNTER IN
OUR- PRACTICE HERE BECAUSE WE DO
REPRESENT- YOUTH WERE ALSO
PARENTS THEMSELVES SO. SOME OF
OUR OLDER TEENAGE CLIENTS. ARE
THEMSELVES PARENTING AND THEY DO
FIND THEMSELVES IN RELATIONSHIPS
OR VIOLENCE IS AN ISSUE BUT
INSTEAD OF TEACHING THEM ABOUT
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS OR
DRESSING THEIR OWN TRAUMA. AGAIN
WE GO TO THAT ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION WHICH IS TO REMOVE
THEIR CHILDREN. BUT THAT'S NOT A
DRESSING FOR THE SUPPORTS THEY
NEED THE DEVELOPMENT OF HEALTHY
RESPECTFUL NONVIOLENT
RELATIONSHIPS. TEACHING
TEENAGERS HOW TO MAINTAIN A
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP AND
DEVELOPING SKILLS ABOUT MANAGING
THEIR FEELINGS ARE COMMUNICATING
IN A HEALTHY WAY. YOU KNOW
FOCUSING ON PREVENTION MEASURES-
LIKE HAVING SUPPORT SYSTEM FROM
THEIR PEERS AND THEIR FAMILIES-
AND REALLY AGAIN JUST NOT
LOOKING. TOO WHAT THEY ARE-
VICTIM NEEDS WHAT A FAMILY
MEANS- AND AGAIN LOOKING. AT SO
WHERE ARE THE- AREAS WE CAN. AND
WE DO FEEL THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS ONE A DRY- THIS ISSUE AS
WELL AS WE CAN BE AS A LACK OF
TRAINING AND KNOWLEDGE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- FOR THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM- RECOGNIZING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- AGAIN OUR
FIRST PRESENTER ON YEAH YOU KNOW
TALKED ABOUT THE DIFFERENT.
TYPES AND THAT MANY PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY GO TO PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE- NOT UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE CAN BE FINANCIAL OR
EMOTIONAL OR- AS THE BELL CENTRE
REVIEW PART FOR THE COURSE OF
CONTROL ISSUES. SO WE'RE FAILING
TO EVEN RECOGNIZE THE TYPES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE DIFFERENT
FORMS OF IT HOW CAN WE BE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE-
CORRECT RESOURCES THAT WE EVEN
ARE AWARE OF WHAT RESOURCES
EXIST- AND THEN HOW TO MAKE AN
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENT. OF
WHAT FAMILIES NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD- AND THIS TRAINING AND
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING
NEEDS TO BE BY THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ATTORNEYS-
SOCIAL WORKERS AND OUR JUDICIAL
OFFICERS- ONE AREA WHERE. THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER IS
BEGINNING TO FOCUS IS TURNING
BRAIN INJURY- WE'RE LEARNING-
THAT MANY VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAVE ENCOURAGED MATIC
BRAIN INJURIES. WHICH CAN HAVE A
PHYSIOLOGICAL FACTS FOR SOME
PERIOD AFTER THAT INJURY- AND
INSTEAD OF RECOGNIZING SIGNS OF
THIS TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY- AS
I MEAN I HAD MENTIONED IT
IMPACTS HOW WE LOOK AT A VICTIM.
WE LOOK AT THE WAY THAT THE
PRESIDING AND THAT THEY ARE
UNINVOLVED IN DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE CHILD IF THERE'S AN APATHY
OR AN UNWILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
SERVICES WHEN THERE MAY BE THE
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITION-
AND THE PHYSICAL IMPACT OF A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY AND HOW
IT MIGHT MANIFEST. AS A FAILURE
TO COMPLY OR WHAT WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE FAILURE TO PROTECT-
WE'RE STARTING A PILOT ACTUALLY
I'M HERE TO COLLECT DATA. WE'RE
GOING TO BE SCREENING ARE OUR
COMMERCIAL SEXUALLY- CHILDREN
AND ARE PRAYING APPEARANCE.
YOUTH FOR TRAUMATIC BRAIN
GENERALSHIP INJURIES I'M SORRY
SUSTAINED FROM INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE- OUR CHALLENGE IS GOING
TO BE TOGETHER RESOURCES AND
PROVIDERS TO FURTHER SUPPORT
EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY FOR
CLIENTS AND COURTS. AND COUNSEL-
WITH THE GOAL TO BE TO. THREE
INDIVIDUALIZE QUE CLASE PANTS
ARE MORE ALIGNED WITH BRAIN
TRAUMA- IN HOPES OF IMPROVING
OUTCOMES- THIS GOES BACK TO THE
FURTHER INSTEAD OF LIKE
PROVIDING TRUE PREVENTION
INTERVENTION SERVICES. OFTEN THE
RESPONSE WE SEE AS TRUMP THE
CHILDREN AND PLACE THEM INTO
FOSTER CARE SO WHILE I DISCUSSED
PREVIOUSLY THAT HARM THAT CAN
COME TO THE CHILDREN BY BEING AT
HOME WITH THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE I
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE HARM TO THE FAMILY AND TO
THE CHILD. FROM CHILD WELFARE
INTERVENTION YOU KNOW IN THIS IS
THAT SYSTEM THAT'S COMING INTO
CONTACT- SO. WE'LL HEAR MORE
FROM OTHER ADVOCATES. BUT THE
HARM TO THE FAMILY. IS THE
VICTIM BEING PUNISHED AND I
BELIEVE I CAN COVER THAT A LOT
BY WHEN THEY'RE REACHING OUT FOR
HELP AND THEN THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM BEING PUNISHED FOR
SEEKING HELP. ARMED SERVICES CAN
BE EXTREMELY OVERWHELMING AND
THEY ARE NOT PAID FOR SO WE SET
UP THESE PROGRAMS FOR FAMILIES
TO PARTICIPATE AND WHETHER THAT
BE. A BATTERER'S INTERVENTION
PROGRAM OR PARENTING OR-
COUNSELING- GETTING TO THOSE
SERVICES CAN BE DIFFICULT AND
THERE ARE YOU KNOW A FINANCIAL
BURDEN TO THESE FAMILIES WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING. THE LOSS OF THAT
HAD TO ME ABOUT THE LOSS OF SOME
FINANCIAL SUPPORT- THE FAMILY
CAN SOMETIMES LOSE BENEFITS WHEN
THEIR CHILDREN ARE REMOVED. AND
I GUESS I SAID TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH ALL THE COURT MANDATED
PROGRAMS- AND THEN ANOTHER ONE
WITH TAT WE SEE AND I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S BEEN TOUCHED UPON.
BUT WE OFTENTIMES PENALIZE
FAMILIES IF THERE'S ANY
EXPRESSED INTENT TO REMAIN
TOGETHER AS A FAMILY- AND THERE
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE IF SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS ARE PUT IN PLACE
THIS MAY BE WHAT IS BEST FOR
THAT FAMILY AND ASKING THAT%
FAMILY WHAT THEY NEED. SO THE
ASSUMPTION IS VICTIM SHOULD
IMMEDIATELY LEAVE THE ABUSER OR
THERE IS A FAILURE TO BE TAXED
WHERE THEN THERE MIGHT BE AN
INDIVIDUAL LYSED WAY. TO BETTER
SUPPORT THE FAMILY. AND SHE'S.
THEN THE HARM TO CHILL. WHEN THE
INTERVENTION OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM COMES IN AND
WHERE WE JUST COME IN AND REMOVE
THE CHILD- THAT'S THE TRAUMA
FROM SEPARATION- YOU KNOW IT'S-
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE HARM. TO
CHILDREN IN A HOME WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BUT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ALSO ADDRESS THE
HOME TO BEING REMOVED AND PLACED
IN FOSTER CARE AND THIS
SHOULDN'T BE A DEBATE ABOUT WHAT
IS WORSE WE DON'T WANT TO DO A
BALANCE OF HARMS AND THAT WAY.
WE SHOULD BE WORKING OUT HOW WE
CAN FIX THAT- CELL LOOKING AT
WHAT HAPPENS TO THESE FAMILIES
AND HOW CAN WE BETTER SUPPORT
THEM- BY PROVIDING PROTECTION TO
THE CHILD AND TO- THE VICTIM.
BUT ALSO ENSURING THAT THE
SUPPORTS THAT ARE NEEDED ARE
PROVIDED TO THEM- I BELIEVE I'M
GETTING THE SIGNAL THAT I'M
RUNNING OUT OF TIME SO I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU ALL- FOR YOUR
TIMEAND ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
AND I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT TAX MONEY HOW TO LEAD I
WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO OUR
MEMBERS FOR ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WILL START WITH-
SENATOR W. I DON'T. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR- THEN AND
I WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS
FOR THEIR TESTIMONY ERE TODAY
IT'S IMPORTANT- TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN. ENSURE THAT
THE SYSTEM WORKS BETTER. NOT
ONLY FOR- THE- VICTIMS FOR LACK
OF BETTER WORDS THAT ARE FLEEING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT ALSO THEIR
CHILDREN WE KNOW THAT- THE
TRAUMA. I MEAN IT'S PROBABLY
ALMOST IS DIFFICULT FOR CHILDREN
TO EXPERIENCE THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS THE- VICTIM
THEMSELVES AND- AND MANY OF THEM
CARRY IT WITH THEM. THEIR ENTIRE
LIFE AND I'M I'M WONDERING IF.
IF THE SYSTEM THAT HAS BEEN SET
UP I'M NOT I'M NOT EVEN SURE
THAT IF EVERY SINGLE COUNTY HAS
A CASA. A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE TO- EIGHT AND HERE-
IF YOU WELL THAT'S NOT INVOLVED
IN THE- OUTCOME OF ANY
PROCEEDING- TO THE CHILDREN
WHETHER THAT'S A- A VALUABLE
SOURCE OR RESOURCE- AND- AND
WHAT THE- WHAT THE- WHAT ARE THE
SOLUTIONS TO. TRYING TO PROVIDE
SOME ASSISTANCE TO THE CHILDREN
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HEARD IN A COURT ROOM SETTING AS
WELL. BETTER HAVE YOUR THAT WAS
DIRECTED TOWARDS ME. I BELIEVE
SO YES OKAY- N. AS- OF FAR AS
CAUSES AN LA COUNTY- AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THE COUNTY IS
WE PRACTICED AND WE DO HAVE
COSTS AS AND WE DO UTILIZE THEM-
AND TO MAKE IT CLEAR AS
ATTORNEYS FOR THE CHILDREN WE
ARE THE VOICE OF THE CHILDREN.
SO WE'D YOU- INTERVIEW THE
CHILDREN WE DO INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS AND WE BRING
THAT- THAT VOICE TO THE COURT
ARMAMENT. OBVIOUSLY DEPENDING ON
THE CHILD'S AGE THAT BERRIES- WE
DO HAVE TO- BUT GETTING TOO
TECHNICAL MINORS COUNCIL IN
CALIFORNIA HOLD A DUAL ROLE
WHERE WE LOOK AT THE CHILD'S
BEST INTEREST AS WELL AS THEIR
STATED INTERESTS- AND I CAN
DEPEND ON. YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY ON
THE AGE OF THE CHILD SO WE ARE
THERE IS ALWAYS A CHILD BECAUSE
AS OBVIOUSLY A GREAT RESOURCE
AND CAN BE ASSIGNED- BY CASE BY
CASE BASIS SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE
ANOTHER. OUTLET BUT WE ARE THAT
WAYS WE DO THE INDEPENDENT
RELATIONS I THINK THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE'RE SORT OF LOOKING AT
AND WARS I TRANSPIRED FIRST
PANELIST- IS IN THE FAILURE TO
PROTECT AROUND- AND JUST MORE SO
JUST NOT HAVING THIS ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE FAMILY AND WHAT THEY NEED
AND THAT WHEN SOMEONE REACHES
OUT FOR HELP THAT THERE IS NOT A
PUNITIVE THE FACT THAT WE ARE.
REALLY COMING TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT- AND I THINK JUST THE
WAY THAT THE CURRENT O'CLOCK
STATUTE AS WRITTEN AND SORT OF
HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED MARCEL-
THOSE SUPPORTS. ARE ALWAYS PUT
IN PLACE. AND- I WAS AT THE
FOREFRONT WE ANT TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM HARM- WE WANT TO
PROTECT FAMILIES- BUT SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU GO TO YOUR IMMEDIATE
REACTION IS JUST REMOVE AND
SEPARATE- WITHOUT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE ADDITIONAL TRAUMA
THAT IS BEING PUT ON THAT CHILD.
FROM THAT SEPARATION. GOT IT I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS- THAT NOT
EVERY FAMILY ENTERS THE COURT
SYSTEM IN THE SAME WAY. AND- I
HAVEN'T PRACTICED LAW. FOR A FEW
YEARS NOW- BUT WHEN I DID WHEN I
HAD MY LOT MY OWN LAW PRACTICE
SITE I TOOK THREE HUNDRED AND
SIX HUNDRED CASES COURT
APPOINTED AND REPRESENTED
PARENTS AND- CHILDREN DEPENDING
ON. THE LANGUAGE ABILITY OF THE
PARENTS- MANY TIMES I WAS
APPOINTED TO BECAUSE I SPOKE
SPANISH BUT- BUT MY REAL CONCERN
IS THAT- IS IT WHEN YOU. WHEN
YOUR COURT APPOINTED IT'S
USUALLY BECAUSE A CHILD IS
ALREADY GOING TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE HOME AND THE ONES THAT WE
DID THAT I DIDN'T GET COURT
APPOINTED ON WERE THE ONES THAT
WENT THROUGH THE DAY THE-
DVORCE OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SYSTEM THAT THEY DIDN'T END UP
AS PART OF A THREE HUNDRED OR
SIX HUNDRED CASES AND SO- AND
KNOWS CHECK CHILDREN- MANY TIMES
WERE NOT REPRESENTED IN COURT-
IT WAS THE PARENTS FIGHTING
FIGHTING IT OUT OR THE- OR- OR-
THE VICTIM- IF THERE WAS NEVER A
DIVORCE PROCEEDING OR CUSTODY
PROCEEDING THAT KID'S- WISHES
WERE NEVER. REALLY TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT AND I GUESS I'M JUST THE
SYSTEM IS A COMPLICATED SYSTEM
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU INTERPRET
AND I'M- AND THE MORE
FLEXIBILITY WE GIVE TO JUDGES
THE MORE DIFFERENCE IN TREATMENT
YOU SEE- AND SO WE'RE WE'RE IN
A- I GUESS WORK I THINK OUR
INTEREST IS MAKING SURE THAT-
WE'RE PROTECTING THE INTERESTS
OF THE CHILD AND THE VICTIMS.
AND THAT THERE'S A SYSTEM IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM
. WITH THE SUPPORTS THAT THEY
NEED AND I DIDN'T ALWAYS SEE
THAT IN THE COURT I GUESS THAT'S
MY BIGGEST CONCERN- YES. YEAH
AND I'VE I CAN BRIEFLY ADDRESSED
THAT I WORKED IN THE I WAS A
FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY- AND THAT
WAS
KNOW HAVE A VOICE EXCEPT IN VERY
LIMITED SITUATIONS WHERE. MINORS
COUNCIL WAS APPOINTED- BUT THAT
WAS A RARE- AND IT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS I AM. AN ORGANIZATION
WHERE EVERY CHILD HAS A VOICE-
BUT I THINK ONE THING AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE TOUCHED ON
IT- BUT IS. IN THE BEGINNING IS
SORT OF THE PREVENTION SERVICES.
IS WORKING WITH SYSTEMS THAT
COME INTO CONTACT WITH THESE
FAMILIES- TO PREVENT THIS SORT
OF THE FILINGS OF THESE CASES IN
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM WORKS TO
HELP FAMILIES EVEN IN THE FAMILY
LAW SYSTEM. SO IT'S PUTTING IN
THOSE PREVENTION SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS- THAT YOU KNOW. WHAT I
GUESS RIGHT AWAY THAT YOU KNOW
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE ISSUES
ADDRESSED BEFORE THEY HAVE TO
EVEN COME UNDER OUR SYSTEM I
REALIZE IN THE FAMILY SYSTEM
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT BITES-
I THINK IT COMES TO YOU KNOW
BETTER TRAINING- AND FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS AND FOR THOSE THAT ARE
COMING INTO CONTACT WITH THESE
FAMILIES- I THINK WE'VE HEARD
TODAY JUST A VARIETY OF WAYS
THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- CAN
MANIFEST AND MANY PEOPLE AREN'T
AWARE OF THAT- SO BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS IN A PREVENTATIVE
MANNER EARLY ON. I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S THAT'S REALLY I
GUESS WHAT I WAS GETTING TO IS
THE SUPPORT SERVICES SO THAT. WE
DON'T END UP IN THIS IN THE
SYSTEM. OURSELVES FAMILIES DON'T
END UP IN THE SYSTEM IF THEY CAN
AVOID IT THEY CAN MAKE THE
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES ABOUT
HAVING TO GO TO COURT AND- FIGHT
IT OUT IN FRONT OF A JUDGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WILL NOW
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR SKINNER. ALL PASSWORD QUESTIONS THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- THAT
WAS- BILLION LIGHTNING AND I
THINK YOU TOUCHED ON SOMETHING
THAT JUST CAUGHT MY ATTENTION
WHICH IS THE INTERGENERATIONAL
VIOLENCE ON AND WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE VICTIMS OF THE CHILDREN
IMPACTED BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
AND I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW BEING A
TEACHER FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS-
USUALLY I CAN SPOT SOMEONE. A
CHILD THAT'S BEEN EXPERIENCING
SOME TRAUMA IN THE HOME BECAUSE
YOU START SEEING SOME OF THE
CHANGES IN ACADEMIC. UPGRADES
AND CHANGES IN BEHAVIOR AND SO
ONE OF MY BIGGEST CONCERNS AND
CHALLENGES WHAT YOU STATED- WHEN
YOU REMOVE A CHILD FROM A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOME. THEY
DON'T HAVE NECESSARILY A GOOD
MODEL OF WHAT A HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP IS THEY DON'T HAVE.
ANY OTHER EXAMPLE SO IT'S I
GUESS IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO EXPLORE A
LITTLE FURTHER HAD DO WE GET
THOSE SERVICES TO THOSE.
CHILDREN IMPACTED BY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOW DO WE GET THE MOM
TO TWENTY STAND WHAT A HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP IS AND SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT- I WOULD JUST
KEEP IN THE BACK OF MY MIND AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO CHANGE THAT BEHAVIOR SO IT
DOESN'T CONTINUE GENERATIONALLY
STILL. THANK YOU FOR THAT SO NOW
WE WILL MOVE OVER TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER- NEXT IS BRAIN OKAMOTO
MR OKAMOTO. IS A PUBLIC DEFENDER
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND HAS BEEN
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS AND BRIAN
ALSO SERVES AS A MEMBER OF THE
JUVENILE COURT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. COMMITTEE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS WELCOME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT SENATOR AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HOSTING THIS.
THIS FORM SO THAT WE CAN. SHARE
OUR EXPERIENCES AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR OPEN MINDEDNESS TO IT ALL I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTERS- INFORMATION IS
ABSOLUTELY ENLIGHTENING THERE IS
SOME OVERLAP WITH. FINE AND I'LL
TRY NOT TO OVERLAP TOO MUCH BUT
I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
POINTS THAT. YOU COULD HELP ME
ALL THREE HAVE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES WE'RE ALL SAYING
THE SAME THANKS AND I THINK
THAT'S TELLING. SO I MY NAME IS
BRIAN OKAMOTO I AM A PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN ORANGE COUNTY I DID
CRIMINAL LAW FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
AND NOW INDEPENDENT STATES IN
AFRICA. OR WHEREVER SENT
PARENTS. THE LAWS OBVIOUSLY
DIFFERENT HERE THAN IT CRAMPED
THE POPULATION WE SERVICE THE
SAME. A SEMESTER HERE ARE.
PARENTS WHO STRUGGLE WITH ABJECT
POVERTY. SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES-
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MENTAL HEALTH.
AND SOME AND OFTEN THESE THESE
SYMPTOMS THAT WE SEE. ARE
EXACERBATED BY THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THAT REMOVES CHOKE. SO
WHAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT TODAY-
ARE BASICALLY TWO THINGS ONE- I
DON'T WANNA GO OVER TOO MUCH IN
THE LAW I THINK THAT'S BEEN
COVERED BUT I DID WANT TO TOUCH
UPON THAT. BUT ALSO TO DESCRIBE
THAT FROM MY POINT OF VIEW OF
HOW THE SYSTEM ACTUALLY WORKS.
AND I HOPE THAT AS I TALK ABOUT
THESE TOPICS THAT THE FEW POINTS
REALLY CUT TO LIGHT. ONE IS THAT
THE STATUTES AND STANDARDS OF
REVIEW THAT GOVERN OUR DECISIONS
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HERE IN
DEPENDENCY. ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
BIAS SEES AND MISGUIDED
PRECONCEPTIONS OKAY DO ALLOW FOR
PUNITIVE AND SOMETIMES
OVERSIMPLIFIED REACTIONS THAT
CAN PUNISH NOT JUST DEFENDING
PARENTS. BUT THE ABUSE THE
PARENTS AS WELL AND EVEN THE
CHILD AND I THINK THE PREVIOUS
PANELISTS ADDRESSED THAT. TOO
THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
COMPLEX AND NUANCED AND JOE WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS ALREADY AND
THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
APPROACHING- ADDRESSING THESE
FAMILIES AND DEPENDENCY COURTS
WITH A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH THAT'S NOT JUST ASK THE
DETERMINATIONS THAT WE MAKE
COURT SUCH AS WHETHER OR NOT WE
START JURISDICTION. OR MOVE
CHOKE AND RETURN SHELLS BUT IT
ALSO HAS TO DO WITH HOW WE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THESE
FAMILIES WE SHOULD NOT HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
THAT AS WELL. AS THIRD THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN RECENT APPELLATE
OPINIONS TO TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INDEPENDENT STATE. AND
WHILE THOSE OPINIONS ARE
EXTREMELY ENCOURAGING BECAUSE OF
BRINGING TO LIGHT. A LOT OF THE
CAR THAT THE IT. THE RESEARCH
UNDER BUYING AND GIVING SOME
MORE ACCURATE ON THAT. THEY'RE
ALSO CONCERNING BECAUSE HE'S OUR
RECENT OPINIONS AND THOSE
DECISIONS ARE BASED ON. IT HE-
ARGUMENTS AND DECISIONS MADE IN
OUR TRIAL COURTS AND WHAT THEY
DO IS THEY REVEAL. THAT OUR
SYSTEM HERE SOMETIMES WILL
OPERATE ON A MISGUIDED CULTURE.
A MISUNDERSTANDING OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR EDUCATION REFORM. AND
SO I APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
I'M A LET ME JUST JUMP IN. SO
JULIE MENTIONED THAT I WOULD BE
TOUCHING ON SECTION. B. AND I
KNOW THAT ON YOUR ALREADY
ADDRESSED AS WELL SO THIS IS
JURISDICTION WHEN THE COURT
TAKES JURISDICTION OVER CASE THE
COURT HEARING DEPENDENCY TEXTERS
DICTION OVER THE CHILD NOT THE
PARENTS. THE PURPOSE OF
DEPENDENCY IS NOT TO PUNISH
PARENTS TO PROTECT CHILDREN AND
TO REUNIFY FAMILIES THOSE ARE
MANDATES. SO THREE HUNDRED B. IS
THE CODE SECTION THAT WE REFER
TO AS THE FAILURE TO EXTRACT
YOUR- BASICALLY THREE ELEMENTS
THE COURTS LOOKING FOR ONE WAS
THERE JUST THE PARENT. IS THE
PARENT UNABLE TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY SUPERVISION OR
PROTECTION OF THE CHILD. AND
CAUSATION YES THAT'S TRUE. THREE
SERIOUS PHYSICAL HARM. OR
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF
EITHER. SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT BURTON. RIGHT SO IS THIS A
HIGH BURDEN IT'S ARGUABLY IT
WOULD BE GREAT BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT ANY KIND
OF RISK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SUBSTANTIAL RISK RIGHT NOW WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT ANY KIND OF
PHYSICAL MEMORY ON THIS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. SERIOUS PHYSICAL
HARM ADULTS WHAT EXACTLY DO
THESE TERMS MEAN SUBSTANTIAL OR
SERIOUS AND WHERE IS THAT LINE.
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHEN IT IS
A RISK VERSUS A SERIOUS RISK
WHERE THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL YES
OR- OR JUST A REGULAR RISK WHO
MAKES THOSE DETERMINATIONS
BECAUSE THE CODE DOESN'T PROVIDE
US A CLEAR DEFINITION. WHERE
THAT LINE IT'S- SO THE ANSWER TO
THAT. AND WHO PROVIDES THIS LINE
. IS US THE PRACTITIONER. IT'S
THE JUDGES IT'S THE SOCIAL
WORKERS ALL OF US ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE TRYING TO APPLY THE
STANDARD. AND THE MOST UNIFORM
WAY POSSIBLE. BUT WE'RE HUMANS
AND WE ALL BRING FORCED OUR
UNDERSTANDINGS OR
INTERPRETATIONS CIRCUMSTANCE
FACTS AND YES MR VIOLENCE. AND
THAT SHOULD BE CONCERNING
SOMETIMES. BUT THE ROLE OF THE
SOCIAL WORKER IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL AS WELL BECAUSE THE
SOCIAL WORKERS MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO WORK TO THE
COURT WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD
ASSERT JURISDICTION WHETHER OR
NOT WE SHOULD REMOVE CHILDREN'S
PARENTS THE SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
GIVING THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
ARE GIVEN GREAT WEIGHT BY THE
JUDGE RIGHT. BECAUSE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE DEEMED AS IMPARTIAL
ARMS OF THE COURT. IN FACT
HEARSAY IS ADMISSIBLE IN THE
SOCIAL WORK REPORTS BECAUSE OF
THEIR RECOGNIZED
PROFESSIONALISM- THAT THEY'RE
RELIABLE AND THAT THEIR
UNBIASED. SO IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL EVERYONE IN OUR SYSTEM
AND ESPECIALLY THE SOCIAL
WORKERS INVOLVED ARE UP TO DATE
AND AWARE. OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND THEIR ACT THEY HAVE AN
ACCURATE UNDERSTANDING OF THAT
BECAUSE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
CARRY GREAT WEIGHT IN OUR
COURTS. SO IF WE DON'T IF WE S.
PROTECT ACTIVE SHOOTERS JUDGES
AND SOCIAL WORKERS DON'T FULLY
REALIZE THE REALITIES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. BUT OFTEN
TIMES WE'LL DO IS WE'LL RELY
TRANSIENTS AND PRECONCEPTIONS
AND THAT MAKES US GROUND. AROUND
HIS DECISION FAMILIES ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES. LIKE WHETHER
OR NOT WE SHOULD REUNIFY
FAMILIES WITH SEPARATED CHILD
FROM THE PARENTS. RIGHT AND
SLIPS FURTHER TRAUMA IN CHILDREN
AND WORST CASE SCENARIO EVEN
TERMINATION OF PARENTAL RIGHTS.
SO IN PRACTICE WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE WE'VE HEARD BOTH PANELISTS
TALKED ABOUT FAILURE TO PROTECT.
THE AREA WHERE WE CAN SOMETIMES
ACTUALLY REMOVE A CHILD FROM AN
ABUSIVE PARENT AND I'VE HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY CLIENTS
BUT THAT IS BEING DISCUSSED. AND
WE'RE ON THE BRINK OF THE COURT
REMOVING THE CHILD FROM THAT
PARENTS CARE. THAT PARENT LOOKS
AT ME CONFUSED WONDERING WHY.
HAVING JUST BEEN ABUSE. THE
COURT WOULD TAKE AWAY MY CHILD.
WHY WOULD THE COURT. TO THAT
TRAUMA WITH ADDITIONAL TRAUMA BY
REMOVING THAT CHILD IT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRAGIC FOR THE
CHILD'S SPOT ACTUALLY AND IT'S
TRAGIC FOR THAT PARENT AS WELL-
THE PARENT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THE SYSTEM WOULD WANT TO.
PLACE THAT CHILD. IN A
STRANGER'S HOME. FOR A COTTAGE
WITH OTHER STRANGERS IN THE
CHILD NOT KNOWING WHEN HERE
SHE'S GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
PARENTS AND ESPECIALLY AT THIS
IMPORTANT INSTANCE FRIGHTENING
TIME AFTER A MASSIVE PROBLEMS
OCCURRED. THESE ARE REAL
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
SYSTEM AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME DEBATE ON THIS TOPIC AND
HOW WE SHOULD PROBABLY WEAR THIS
BUT I THINK AS A STARTING POINT
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE. THAT WE TO
PAUSE. BEFORE WE DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS WE SHOULD HAVE WE
SHOULD HAVE GUIDELINES IN PLACE
TO PREVENT THIS OR MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT- I KNOW IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED. BUT I THINK IF WE ALL
FOCUS ON THE TRAUMA THAT BOTH
CHILDREN AND PARENTS SUFFER FROM
THIS REMOVAL UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE CAN COME
TO A CONSENSUS. IN SOME WAY AND
SO I. ACTUALLY APPLAUD. SENATE
ROUTE SENATOR RUBIO AND
EVERYONE'S EFFORTS TO GET
SOMETHING PASSED ON THIS END I
GRATEFUL FOR THE VOICES BEFORE
ME THAT SPOKE ON THIS AS WELL.
SO IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT BY.
JULIE ABOUT- ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
DEPENDENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THAT IS FRONT
AND CENTER ONE OF MY STUDENTS
BECAUSE THE EASIER CASES ACTION
OKAY RIGHT EASIER. BUT THE
OBVIOUS CASES ARE THOSE WHERE WE
SEE CLEARLY WHO THE ABUSER ISN'T
WRITTEN IT IS S. BUT SOMETIMES
IT'S NOT SO CRYSTAL CLEAR. AND
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
BEST THAT VIOLENCE. SHOULD BE
EXHIBITED IN DIFFERENT WEIGHTS
THERE ARE PATTERNS AND CYCLES OF
VIOLENCE BUT THEY'RE ALSO
DIFFERENT DEGREES OF THAT. AND
THERE ARE TIMES ABSOLUTELY
INTERVENE AND REMOVE CHILDREN
BUT THERE ARE ALSO TIMES AND WE
SHOULDN'T EVEN EXERCISE
JURISDICTION IN THE CASE. AND
IT'S THOSE NUANCES THAT I THINK
SOMETIMES GET LOST WE APPROACH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH WE HAVEN'T READ
OVER REACTS AND STATS WE SHOULD
WE SHOULD HAVE TO. WHAT WE END
UP TRAUMATISING CHILDREN IN THE
PROCESS. SO- WHAT WHAT DOES THAT
LIKE WHAT. I WILL TO TALK ABOUT
THESE OPINION BECAUSE THAT WAY
IT'S NOT JUST ME SPOUTING OUT
SOME OF THE THINGS I'VE
EXPERIENCED IN MY KIDS. YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE COURT OPINIONS AND
SEE WHAT OCCURRED. IN RACHAEL L.
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE CASE IT
JUST CAME DOWN RECENTLY. AND IN
THIS CASE THE COURT OF APPEALS
FOUND THAT THE JUVENILE COURT
AARON EACH FINDING JURISDICTION.
AND TEAR THE JUVENILE COURT
FOUND THAT THERE WAS
JURISDICTION UNDER THREE HUNDRED
FEET. BECAUSE OF THE PARENTS
LONG HISTORY. OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISSUES AND THE MOTHER'S
REFUSAL TO PARTICIPATE IN
SERVICES THE SERVICES WORK ORDER
. AND THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
MULTIPLE ACTS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OVER EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME. IN FACT THERE WAS ONE
INCIDENT IT WAS AN INCIDENT
INVOLVING QUESTION SHOVING AND
GRABBING OVER A CELL PHONE THAT
OCCURRED NINE MONTHS PRIOR TO
THE HEARING. SO NINE MONTHS THE
MOTHER LIVE WITH A CHILD WITH NO
PROBLEMS THERE WAS NO ACCIDENTS
THE PILOTS THE FATHER'S
WHEREABOUTS WERE UNKNOWN AND
MOM. VINGTAINE A RESTRAINING
ORDER. THE COURT APPEALS
DISMISSED THIS PETITION. AND SO
WHAT IT SAYS LOOK WE CAN APPLY
THE CORPORATE FROM BRITAIN'S
DECISION BUT WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT THE TRIAL.
COURT MADE A DECISION. FOR
JURISDICTION. WITHOUT SUPPORTING
EVIDENCE. AND THAT IS JUST ONE
CASE THERE ARE OTHERS. SO IT
BEGS THE QUESTION. WHAT EXACTLY
IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THEN THAT
WOULD SUPPORT YOUR SECTION WHAT
IS EXACTLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WE
SOMETIMES ANSWER THIS BY OUR
WITH OUR EXPECTATIONS AND OUR
PRECONCEPTIONS. WITH THIS ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH EFFECTIVE
VICTIM MUST LOOK LOOK A CERTAIN
WAY OR BEHAVE A CERTAIN WAY IT'S
A BIG IF THE VICTIM MOTHER IS
NOT DOING SERVICES THAT MEAN SHE
DOESN'T CARE RIGHT. IF SHE'S NOT
SOFT SPOKEN OR SEEMINGLY
FRIGHTENS THAT WE ASSUME THAT
SHE MIGHT BE JUST MORE
AGGRESSIVE OR MORE DIFFICULT
THERE IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH THIS AND I THINK IT
DOWN ON YOUR BED MENTION THIS
THAT SOMETIMES THAT BATTERS YOU
REALLY SOPHISTICATED AND MAKE IT
THEIR OWN AND WIN OVER SOCIAL
WORKERS AND JUDGES IT COULD BE
CHARISMATIC RELATE TO AUTHORITY
FIGURES. AND THEY CAN THEY CAN.
GET IT VANISHED IN THESE COURTS
OVER- SO. WE'RE OVERLOOKING AS
THE TRUE VICTIM. SO THERE ARE
SOME OF THIS OF HOW WE HAVE
THESE EXPECTATIONS ROLES RIGHT
I'D E IS A TWENTY TWENTY SIX
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE WALL
OF A SO CALLED VICTIM ISN'T
REALLY CLEAR THE CASE CAME IN
BECAUSE THE MOTHER LASHED OUT AT
HER USER I. THROWING SOMETHING
ADAM BUT LATER IT WAS REVEALED
THAT THE FATHER HAD JEALOUS
RAGES ISOLATOR IS ECHOED USE
THAT ANGER HER VERBAL ABUSE TO
HARM HERSELF STEAM AND
INDEPENDENCE AND TAUNTED HER
KNOWING ME KNOWING THAT IT WOULD
TRIGGER A PHYSICAL REACTION. SO
NOT ALWAYS. AND I THINK WE
SHOULD AVOID MAKING BREAST RUSS
SNAP JUDGMENTS ON THIS- AND WHAT
WE EXPECTED THEM TO ACT LIKE SO-
ANY CASE IN REMEDY WHICH IS ALSO
TWENTY TWENTY CASE MY
JURISDICTION. IN THAT CASE THE
JUVENILE COURT FOCUSED ON
MOTHER'S PAST AS A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND NOTED THAT
SHE WAS UNCOOPERATIVE THE
SUBSTANCE SIX DESPITE BEING TEN
MONTHS FREE THE FATHER. THE
COURT STILL- TOOK ISSUE WITH
MOM- HE RECORDED APPEALS
RECOGNIZED STATED THIS ACTUALLY.
THERE WAS A RECENT TROUBLING
TREND OF WHAT THEY PERCEIVE AS
MOTHERS BEING VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND THAT MAY
BE ADDED THIS QUOTE WE EXPECT
SUCH VICTIMS TO BE SWEET TRYING
TO WEAR BLACK LESS FRIGHTENED
AND HELP US AND NOT. A
MULTIFACETED WOMAN WHO MAY OR
MAY NOT EXPERIENCE FEAR ANGER.
THESE ARE THE PRECONCEPTIONS
THAT JUDGES AND JURORS BRING
WITH THEM INTO THE COURTROOM AND
DISTRUST OF RATIONALLY OCCURRED
STORY WE ENCOURAGE CONTINUED
DILIGENCE AND EDUCATION TO GUARD
AGAINST SUCH PRECONCEPTIONS.
WHAT ELSE DO WE IMPOSE OUR
EXPECTATIONS WE HAVE THIS
EXPECTATION THAT IN ORDER TO
REUNIFY THE FAMILY OR CLOSE THE
CASE OR ALLOW THE CHILDREN TO
REMAIN WITH THE NOT SO CALLED
NOT AFFECTING. THE PARENT HAS TO
DEMONSTRATE A SEPARATION FROM
THE ABUSER BUT THAT'S ALSO A
NEBULOUS CONCEPT BECAUSE- HOW
LONG DOES THE PARENT HAVE TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THE ABUSER. IN A
CASE THEN IN THAT CASE AND MAY I
BE THAT TWENTY TWENTY CASE IN
THAT CASE THAT THE JUVENILE
COURT FOUND THAT EIGHT MONTHS OF
SEPARATION JUST WASN'T. AGAIN
RELIED ON THE HISTORY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND THE
ARGUMENTS AND THERE WERE QUITE
SHOCKING- MINUS COUNSELING AND
THE COUNTY COUNCIL'S SOCIAL
SERVICES ARGUED THAT THERE WAS
QUOTE NO TRUE CHANGE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE APART. AND
HER PAST FAILURES TO SEPARATE
YOURSELF FROM THE FATHER WERE
CONCLUSIVE PROOF THAT THE
INSPIRATION SHOULD PUT PROCESSED
AND ONE EVEN ARGUED THAT THE
BROTHERS QUOTE COMPULSIVE
INVOLVEMENT. BUT THE FATHER- HAD
NOT CEASED. THIS RECORD REPEAL
TOOK ISSUE WITH IT SAID THAT
THERE'S A SHOCKING LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SUCH AS
COMPULSIVE INVOLVEMENT
PERPETUATE THE MYTH OF THE HELP
WAS WITH BATTERED WOMEN. THIS IS
AGAIN AN EXAMPLE OF US IMPOSING
OUR EXPECTATIONS. ON HOW-
SURVIVORS NEED TO ACT BEFORE WE
EITHER RETURN THEIR CHILDREN.
THOSE CASES OR SEARCH OUR
RESTRICTION ON AND WE CAN BE
MISGUIDED ON THIS- WHEN WE BRING
THOSE STANDARDS AND WE ON'T
APPLY- STANDARDS THAT WE SHOULD
BE APPLYING. BUT AGAIN BECAUSE
THOSE TERMS LIKE SUBSTANTIAL
RISK SERIOUS PHYSICAL HARM QUITE
NEBULOUS IT DOES LEAVE ROOM FOR
SOME OF THESE INTERPRETATIONS-
FORTUNATELY THE COURTS OF APPEAL
HAVE BANNED UP VIGILANT. AND
HAVE ASSISTED ON THIS SO WHAT
STANDARD SHOULD GOVERN. AGAIN
SUBSTANTIAL RISK YOUR SPECIAL
CRIME THESE ARE NEBULOUS TERMS
AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
DEPENDENCIES SPECIAL RECESSING
FOR SCHOOL A SUBSTANTIAL RISK
IS. SOMEWHAT LIKE. PREDICTING
ALMOST LIKE GAZING INTO A
CRYSTAL BALL AND TRYING TO GUESS
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS GOING TO
BE AT RISK RIGHT. OUR SYSTEM
COURT ALSO TWENTY TWENTY JETS
FAMILY WAS AT THE EIGHTEEN MONTH
REVIEW MEETING AT THAT REGIS IS
A STATUS STATUTORY STATUS
RENEWED EXPECTATIONS SHORT.
UNLESS THERE IS EVIDENCE OF A
SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF DETRIMENT.
HERE AGAIN THERE'S THAT WORD
SUBSTANTIAL RIGHT- HERE THE
SOCIAL WORKER APPLYING TO THE
PARENTS HAD IT RESOLVED THEIR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUES AND IN
THE COURT ADOPTED THE
RECOMMENDATION AND TERMINATE
SERVICES AND BY THE WAY WHEN
SERVICES ARE TERMINATED THE CASE
IS NOW ON THE DOORSTEP. TO
TERMINATION OF PARENTAL RIGHTS
AND IN MANY INSTANCES. THING
HERE THOUGH AS BOTH PARENTS
FULLY PARTICIPATED IN THE
SERVICE THAT'S- MOTHER HAD A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUE. THE CASE
THAT THE COURT ACKNOWLEDGED WAS
NO LONGER A CONCERN. BUT THE
SOCIAL WORKER TESTIFIED HER
CONCERN WAS THAT THE PARENTS
CONTINUE TO INTERACT WITH EACH
OTHER EVEN THOUGH THE SOCIAL
WORKER ENCOURAGED PARENTS TO
INTERACT AND CO. BUT THE COURT
WAS STILL CONCERNED WITH PUBLIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE MYSTIC
VIOLENCE POINT AFTER THAT.
THERAPIST FOR THE MOTHER OF MINE
THAT THERE WERE NO CONCERNS THIS
RELATIONSHIP AND THERE WERE NO
CONTRADICTING THERE WAS NO
CONTRADICTING UPDATES. THE COURT
STILL FOUND BOYFRIEND POST RISK
THE PURPOSE OF IT EVEN AFTER
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT BUT IT DIDN'T
HAVE ANY THERE WERE NO CONCERNS
ABOUT MONTHS RT. AS THE DATA IN
THE CASE THE COURT FOUND THAT HE
HAD IN FACT INSECT. DIDN'T SAY
WHAT EVIDENCE SUPPORTED THAT
FINDING A LACK OF INSIGHT. ALSO
SO THAT THE PARENTS SEEM TO
LINGER IN THE RELATIONSHIP BUT
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE THEY
MAINTAIN A RELATIONSHIP. THE
COURT OF APPEALS. REVERSED
THAT'S WELL. IT COULD BE SO AS A
BRICK. FOR HAD TO WAIT FIVE
MONTHS FOR THAT DECISION TAP.
THEY WOULD NOW HAVE TO RECOVER
AND REBUILD SOME OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. SO- HOW DO WE
DETERMINE WHO AT AN ARAB WE HAVE
ABOUT TWO MORE MINUTES AHA YOU
MAY BE AT ME WRAPPED UP THANK
YOU FOR THAT OKAY SO ONE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE- FORMULAIC RESPONSE
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT WE JUST
BASICALLY SAY HERE'S A DV CASE
BAGHDAD MOVED OUT BOMB GET
KICKED BACK IT GOT PARTICIPATE
IN YOUR PERSONAL POWER PROGRAM
DAD GO DO YOUR SERVICES WILL
KEEP THE FAMILY SEPARATED THEN
WE'LL CLOSE THE CASE WITH EXIT
ORDERS BUT WHAT WE'VE DONE THERE
IS WHICH SEPARATED THE FAMILY WE
HAVEN'T BEGUN TO FIGHT THEM. AND
THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE ARE
WE REALLY TRYING TO BRING THE
FAMILIES BACK TOGETHER AGAIN- WE
JUST GIVING STRAIGHTFORWARD
SERVICES LIKE GENERAL SERVICES
LIKE CLASSES INSTEAD OF INTO
INDIVIDUAL THERAPY AND
COUNSELING SO WHAT SHOULD WE DO
I THINK WE NEED JUST CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON OUR MANDATE OF. NOT
SEPARATE FAMILIES AND KEEP IT
SEPARATE ACCEPT IT THERE ARE
TIMES WE HAVE TO BUT THERE ARE
TIMES WE SHOULD ALSO BE TRYING
TO BRING UP. FAMILY BACK
TOGETHER AGAIN. THANK YOU. THE
CHILD DOESN'T BOTH PARENTS AND
HIS OR HER LIFE. AND SOME
INSTANCES. THIS THIS WEEK WE
NEED TO GET TO THE ROOT CAUSES
AND NOT JUST THE SYMPTOMS IN THE
- OF VIOLENCE RED CAUSES LIKE
POVERTY. DEPRESSION AND EVEN THE
PARENTS ON PAST TRAUMA. I'M NOT
NAIVE TO BELIEVE THAT WE COULD
SOLVE EVERY CASE BUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE SHOULD DEEM EVERY
CASE HOPELESS. AND OUT LASTLY.
THESE CASES THESE APPELLATE
CASES DO GET. BECAUSE THERE'S
RECOGNITION NOW I WHATDOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REALLY IS AND WE HAVE
LAWS THAT WE CAN CITE. BUT STILL
IT FRIGHTENS ME BECAUSE THESE
DECISIONS ARE BASED ON WHAT'S
OCCURRING IN OUR HEARTS. OUR
COURT SYSTEM I THINK IS MAKING
WITH METS WE STILL HAVE ROOM TO
GROW AND I. P. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
AT A PIVOTAL POINT WHERE THERE'S
INTEREST. AND I BELIEVE THAT
WHICH WHILE THE- IRON IS HOT. I
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS FOR
EVERYTHING I KNOW THERE'S NOT
JUST ONE ANSWER AND I KNOW I
HAVE TO DO MY PART TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SYSTEM WORKS. AND BE
INFORMED AND I'M STILL UPBEAT TO
BE TO LEARNING. THE OTHER
PANELISTS AND THE SENATORS
SENATORS. I'M COMFORTED IN
KNOWING THAT THE OTHER PANELISTS
WERE FAR MORE. INFORMED THAN I
AM. ARE HERE TODAY APPLE FINDS
CONCERNS AND THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
EXPRESSING THESE TWO JUDGES WHO
HAVE MINDS MADE UP. CONTINUE
SENATORS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. EYE CARE. EARNESTLY
ABOUT THI POPULATION THAT WE
SERVE. I'M SO GRATEFUL. FOR YOU
SENATOR RUBIO AND TO ALL OF YOU
FOR CONVENING. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN CARING FOR
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I WILL NOW TURN IT
OVER TO MEMBERS OF THE PANEL I'M
SORRY THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION PER SE I MEAN THAT WAS
A LOT THAT YOU CAN BAIT- WHAT I
WOULD APPRECIATE HOWEVER- WE ARE
WE- MANY OF US TAKING NOTES WE
OBVIOUSLY OUR STAFF HERE BUT IF
YOU HAD. IF YOU WERE WILLING TO
SEND A SEND ME EMAIL. A FEW OF
THE CONCRETE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT- BASED ON WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
OBSERVING IN YOUR COMMENTS THAT
WOULD BE REALLY REALLY HELPFUL
PRECIADO. THANK YOU CENTER AND A
COUPLE YET ONLY QUESTIONS- I
JUST WANT TO THANK- I THANK THE
GENTLEMAN FOR MR OKAMOTO FOR-
HIS PRESENTATION I'VE I'VE TAKEN
NOTES IF YOU'VE GOT THE SITES
FOR THOSE CASES THAT WOULD BE
GREAT- ADDED. I'M I'M I'M- I'M
STRUCK BY THE COMMENT ABOUT I'M
NOT HAVE A HAVING A FORMULAIC
APPROACH AND SO JUST SEEMS TO ME
WE MAY WANNA HAVE GUIDELINES OUR
GUIDEPOST. I'M I DIDN'T REALLY
PRACTICED IN PRACTICE IN THE
AREA- THE CIVIL AREA OTHER THAN
THESE COURT APPOINTED CASES THAT
I DID MOST OF MY WORK WAS IN THE
M. CRIMINAL DEFENSE AREA BUT-
IT- IT JUST SEEMS TO ME LIKE
THAT LIKE THE- JUDICIAL COUNCIL
SHOULD HAVE GUIDELINES. THAT
THEY ISSUE THAT GIVES SOME
PARAMETERS AROUND SOME OF THIS
IT IF THAT DOESN'T EXIST MAYBE
WE NEED TO ASK- THAT. THE DATE
THEY PRODUCE THAT BECAUSE THESE
COURT CASES ARE APPALLING- IT
THERE IT'S GREAT THAT THEY WERE
OVERTURNED BUT- BUT NOT TO HAVE
FACTS UPON WHICH TO- TO START
BREAKING UP FAMILIES THAT HAVE
BEEN PARTICIPATING IN PROCESS
SEES. AND DOING THE BEST THEY
CAN I GUESS THAT'S MY CONCERN
BUT THE OTHER THING IS THAT I'M
I'M WONDERING IF ANYBODY'S DONE
ANY. ANY STUDIES AROUND- ABOUT
AROUND IT IMPLICIT. BIAS IN IN
THE SYSTEM- I PRACTICED IN
MOSTLY RURAL AGRICULTURAL AREA
AND- FRANKLY THE JUDGES HAD NO.
OUR CONNECTION TO MOST OF THE
POOR PEOPLE THAT CAME IN THAT
WERE BEFORE THEM AND- IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT WE'RE PROBABLY TAKING
AWAY. CHILDREN THAT. ARE IN
REALLY POOR HOUSEHOLDS MORE THAN
MORE THAN NOT NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO THAT MANY OF THE
TIMES IT'S THE POVERTY
INDICATORS THAT WOULD INDICATE
THE PARENTS ARE NOT DOING A VERY
GOOD JOB OR THAT WOULD LEAD A
JUDGE TO ISSUE OUT REMOVAL A
OPPOSED TO- SOMETHING ELSE IN IN
THE HOUSEHOLD IT'S HAPPENING AND
SO. I JUST- I'M- VERY VERY
CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE SOME
PARAMETERS IN THIS AREA AND
WHETHER WE LEGISLATED. OR WE
DIRECT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
DO IT- WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO
THAT I AGREE WITH THAT. SENATOR
SKINNER WE GOT IT. IF YOU'VE GOT
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS I'D BE
REALLY HELPFUL. THANK YOU MR
AKIMOTO I ALSO WILL AGREE WITH
US MY- SENATOR MEMBERS HERE THAT
IF I IF YOU CAN SEND US THAT
INFORMATION. EMAIL ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU YOU MAY HAVE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO EXPLORE IT AND
I PROCEED TO APPRECIATE THE
CONCRETE EXAMPLES YOU PROVIDED.
FOR US TODAY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE COURT
SYSTEM- FIRST I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE FIRST PANELIST OUT WE
JUST CONCLUDED OUR FIRST PANEL
WHICH WAS FOCUSED ON THE
OVERVIEW OF A CHILD WELFARE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA
COURT SYSTEM. WE WILL NOW MOVE
OVER TO PANEL NUMBER TWO WHICH
WILL FOCUS ON IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN VICTIMS AND
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE WILL START WITH.
JONATHAN WIGGS WHO IS- FROM W.
I'M SORRY YWCA SANK A ROGUE
VALLEY. AND MR WICKS IS A TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE COORDINATOR FOR
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM AT
THE- WHITE W. CA AND SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY THE FLOOR IS YOURS
WELCOME. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY SENATORS IT'S
REALLY COOL. TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK. ON THIS TOPIC- THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE PREVIOUS PRESENTERS-
IT WAS AWESOME TO HEAR FROM YOU
GUYS. I'M ON THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH SIDE OF
THINGS BUT I DO. OFTEN TIMES
HELP CLIENTS WITH THE LEGAL SIDE
OF THE V. SO- IT'S JUST
REFRESHING TO KNOW THAT. WHITE
BRIAN SAID- WE'RE ALL SEEING THE
SAME THINGS EVEN FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- SO I DO HAVE A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON DVD. SO I
DO OUR RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM-
WHICH WE HAVE TWO TRACKS IT'S
EITHER FORTY FIVE DAY EMERGENCY
PROGRAM BUT WE ALSO HAVE A SIX
TO TWELVE MONTH TRANSITIONAL
PROGRAM. SO I DO GET TO SEE AND
WORK WITH FAMILIES THROUGH. A
DIFFERENT TIME. DIFFERENT TIME
IF- AS A KIND OF MOVES FORWARD
FROM THEIR RELATIONSHIPS. WHICH
WE ALSO HAVE A NON RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM OUT OF THE MAIN OFFICE.
WHICH WE DO SUPPORT GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUAL WORK AS WELL AND THE
REALITY IS A LOT OF PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW TV IS SO SUBJECTIVE
DEPENDING ON THE FAMILY AND I
EVERYBODY WANTS TO LEAVE THEIR
PARTNER- SO WE DO GET A PRETTY
GOOD VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PRESENTING CHALLENGES AND SO
I'VE LEARNED A LOT. JUST FROM
BEING HERE- I DID MY INTERNSHIP
HERE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND
THEY HIRED ME AFTER SO IT'S
BEEN. A VERY INSIGHTFUL JOURNEY
. AND- LIKE I SAY I'M JUST
THANKFUL TO BE HERE TODAY. BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT SOME THINGS
SO I KNOW THE GOLFER PANEL CHU
IS IMPROVING OUTCOMES- SO THERE
IS A GOOD AMOUNT OF PREVENTATIVE
THINGS I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT-
BECAUSE AGAIN WITH TV IT'S ONE
OF THOSE SOCIAL ISSUES THAT IT
IS VERY MUCH PRESENT. ARE
PREVENTABLE. LIKE BRIAN SAID
THOUGH NOT YOU KNOW I EVEN
EXPECTED TO GO AWAY COMPLETELY
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
COULD BE DYING BEFORE FAMILIES
HAVE TO COME INTO A PROGRAM LIKE
OURS. OR YOU KNOW PEOPLE GROW UP
WITNESSING TV THERE'S WORK THAT
COULD BE DONE SO THAT THEY ALSO
TURN INTO A PERPETRATOR. ALSO
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT WAS TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. AND SOME OF IT I
THINK I'M SEEING IT RIGHT NOW IN
OUR OWN AGENCY. IS BECAUSE- WE
DO HAVE. I TURNED OVER A RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GETTING TEAM MEMBERS
AND AS THEY COME ON BOARD- THEY
ALSO NEED TO BE TRAUMA INFORMED.
BECAUSE THE TRAUMA INFORMED
PERSON IS A SAFER PERSON. AND SO
IT DOES ALWAYS MAKE ME WONDER
YOU KNOW WHAT IS. THE STANDARD
FOR TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. AND
WHEN I STARTED RESEARCHING AND
TO TRAUMA I WAS KIND OF
SURPRISED THAT THERE'S NOT. SO
MUCH OF A AGREED UPON DEFINITION
OF WHAT TRAUMA IT IS AND I KNOW
WE ALSO GOT INTO THAT TODAY.
TALKING ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
THERE'S NOT REALLY AN AGREED
UPON DEFINITION OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. FOR GOOD REASON
THAT'S SUBJECTIVE BUT- AS FAR AS
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE GOES YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
TRYING TO. RESIST RE
TRAUMATIZING A FAMILY YOU KNOW
THAT'S ALREADY LEAVING A TRAUMA.
I DEFINITELY. DEFINITELY SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. AND SO. YOU KNOW I'M
THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU GET
TRAINED AS A CLINICIAN SOMETIMES
AN EDUCATOR OR A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL. AND YOU LEARN
ABOUT MANDATED REPORTING. AND
IT'S NOT EVEN A QUESTION THAT
YOU KNOW THOSE THINGS YOU NEED
TO LISTEN FOR. WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
CAUSE YOU TO HAVE TO AT LEAST
CONSULT. RIGHT SO WHETHER IT'S-
ARMED FOR SELF HARM TO OTHERS
CHILD ABUSE ELDER ABUSE. IT'S
VERY COMMON KNOWLEDGE. AND I
WOULD HOPE TO SEE YOU GET TO
THAT POINT WITH TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. WHERE WE ALL KNOW THE SIX.
PRINCIPLES OF TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE YOU KNOW- OR WHATEVER IS
IT'S GOING TO BE LANGUAGE WISE I
JUST FEEL LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
ROOM. FOR GROWTH AS FAR AS LIKE
WHAT IS THE STANDARD. FOR TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE OF BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID NOT JUST OUR OWN AGENCY BUT
FOR OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE
SERVING THESE FAMILIES- IF THERE
IS A COMMON APPROACH TO WORKING
WITH THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO TRAUMA. I THINK THAT
COULD DEFINITELY IMPROVE.
OUTCOMES. THE OTHER THING TO.
THE FOLKS. TO IS ON CHILDREN.
IS- AS GUYS OF OUR MET. YOU KNOW
NOT JUST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT
TRAUMA IN GENERAL. IT COULD HAVE
A VERY- COMMON RESPONSE AS FAR
AS THE CHILD'S. SCHOOL
PERFORMANCE AND FELT SOMETHING
THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE HERE
WITHIN OUR PROGRAM THAT WE DO.
AND WE'RE CONNECTED TO SCHOOL ON
WHEELS. AND I DO THINK I'VE SEEN
BY INCREASED. BECAUSE OF COATED
AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF STUDENTS
HAD THEIR WITHDRAWAL BECAUSE OF
THE VIRTUAL SET UP- BUT ON TOP
OF THAT YOU KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
EXPRIENCING TV IN THE HOME.
THERE'S DEFINITELY THAT DROP IN
SCHOOL PERFORMANCE. AND SO
SCHOOL ON WHEELS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO
FOLLOW FAMILIES. IT'S A FANCY
DESIGNED FOR HOMELESS. FAMILIES
BUT A LOT OF IT THERE'S A HUGE
OVERLAP. WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND HOMELESSNESS- I KNOW THERE'S
A PART WHERE. THE MAYOR'S- MERA
REPORT WHERE IT WAS AROUND FORTY
FOUR PERCENT. OF THEM SAID THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A MAJOR
CAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS. SO THERE
IS A HUGE OVERLAP AND I REALLY
LIKE THAT SCHOOL ON WHEELS
FOCUSES ON THAT. AND I CAN LIKE
I SAID THEY'RE ABLE TO FOLLOW
FAMILIES AS THEY REBUILD THEIR
INDEPENDENCE THEIR STABILITY.
AND CELL AGAIN HELPING THE
CHILDREN GET RE ENGAGED WITH
SCHOOL I'VE SEEN IT DO A LOT OF
GOOD- WORK FOR OUR FAMILIES HERE
IN OUR PROGRAM WHERE. THE
CHILDREN DID COMING WITHDRAWN
AND- LIKE I SAID NOT DOING TOO
WELL IN SCHOOL- BUT THEY GET
CONNECTED TO SCHOOL ON WHEELS
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO. GET BACK
INTO THE FLOW OF THEIR ACADEMICS
AND MAKE A LOT OF PROGRESS. AND
SO LIKE I SAID I KNOW THE
SERVICE A LOT OF DIFFERENT-
COUNTIES. SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY INTERCOUNTY-
SUCH A GREAT A GREAT I THINK
STEP TO TRY TO HELP FAMILIES
RECOVER. SARS PREVENTION AND
THERE'S ALSO A REALLY GOOD
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM- SO I GOT
TRAINED ON IT. IT'S THROUGH
FUTURES WITHOUT VIOLENCE THEY'RE
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO- WHICH WAS
A GREAT TRIP TO GOING GET
TRAINED. BY ESSENTIALLY THEY
HAVE EVIDENCE BASED. PROGRAM
CALLED COACHING BOYS INTO MEN-
AS FAR AS PROVING. YOU KNOW THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE. WHERE THE- IS
TO. UTILIZE THE REALITY OF
ATHLETES HAVE AN INFLUENCE ON
THEIR CAMPUSES AND SO COACHING
BOYS INTO MEN. YOU ESSENTIALLY
TRAIN THE COACHES ON THIS. ANTI
VIOLENCE CURRICULUM. AND ONCE A
WEEK TALK TO THEIR PLAYERS
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON. AND LIKE
I SAID IT IS EVIDENCE BASED AND
SO HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIAL AND
WHEN WE'RE TALKING PREVENTION.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THOSE ARE
MULTIPLE OF THOSE PLAYERS ON
THOSE TEAMS MIGHT BE LIVING IN A
HOME. WITH T. V. BUT TO HEAR THE
MESSAGE COMING FROM SOMEONE THEY
LOOK UP TO LIKE THEIR COACH IT
COULD TOTALLY. CHANGE THEIR
DIRECTION OR THEIR TRAJECTORY.
AS FAR AS BEING A PERPETRATOR
THEMSELVES- SO I ACTUALLY JUST
GOT TO. DO A FIRST TRYING TO
INSTALL THAT TRAINING FOR THE
CITY OF AS YOU SAW LAST WEEK. SO
I WAS ABLE TO SIT WITH THIRTEEN
STAFFERS AND EXPLAIN TO THEM
WHAT COACHING BOYS INTO MEN.
ENTAILS AND KIND OF COME UP WITH
A PLAN ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD AND ROLL IT OUT.
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE CITY OF
ITS USE- SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
MAYBE IT'S JUST DO THEIR
COMMUNITY PROGRAM BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER GREAT. PREVENTATIVE
EFFORT I ALSO HAD A REALLY GOOD
DISCUSSION LAST WEEK WITH THE
COUNCILMAN. SHE'S OUT OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND THIS JUST
TO KIND OF TOUCH ON THE BALL
YOU'RE TO PROTECT.
CONVERSATIONAL BEEN HAVING
TODAY. THAT I HAVE SEEN IT A LOT
YOU KNOW WHERE OU'RE GOING AND
FAMILIES THAT COME INTO OUR
SHELTER. UNFORTUNATELY BILL
STILL HAVE THEIR CHILDREN
REMOVED- WHILE THE INVESTIGATION
IS ONGOING. AND THANKFULLY I'VE
SEEN A LOT OF CHILDREN RETURNED
TO THEIR FAMILY. BUT THE POINT
IS THEY WERE SEPARATED FOR THOSE
MONTHS AS THEY DID THEIR
INVESTIGATION. AND I'VE EVEN
UNFORTUNATELY SCENE WHERE THE
CHILDREN GET SENT TO ABUSER. AND
SO. I AM TALKING ABOUT THE
TRAUMA DOES TO NOT ONLY THE
CHILDREN BUT ALSO THE PARENT THE
NON OFFENDING PARENT- THERE'S A
LOT OF ROOM FOR GROWTH. AND SO
THIS COUNCIL I MEAN YOU KNOW HER
VISION AND I KNOW IT'S A FAR OFF
VISION AS FAR AS HOW LONG IT'LL
TAKETO COMPLETE BUT- SHE
ENVISIONED THE FACILITY
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR THOSE
FAMILIES. YOU KNOW WHERE THERE
DOES NEED TO BE ABOUT MONITORING
BUT INSTEAD OF SEPARATING THE
FAMILY THEY ALL GO INTO THIS
PROGRAM. AND LIKE I SAID WE'VE
HAD CLIENTS COME INTO OUR
PROGRAM WHERE. THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE TOLD YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T
GO INTO THE SHELTER YOUR
CHILDREN WILL BE REMOVED. AND SO
THEY COMPLY. THEY COME TO THE
SHELTER AND SOMEHOW THEY STILL
END UP HAVING THE CHILDREN
REMOVED. SO I THINK HAVING A
FACILITY SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
FOR THOSE. TYPES OF FAMILIES
WHERE THERE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
SEVERE. I HAVE A NEED TO KEEP
THE MONITOR IT- THAT WOULD BE
GREAT YOU KNOW SO AGAIN WE CAN
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
HOURS SEPARATING CHILDREN. FROM
NOT SUPPORTIVE PARENT. IN
SOMETHING ELSE YOU KNOW THAT I'M
ALSO HOPING TO SEE HAPPEN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IS OUT OF OHIO.
THEY ARE WORKING RIGHT NOW AND
TRY TO TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
BILL ONLINE. A STATE OF
EMERGENCY ON CHILDHOOD TRAUMA.
AND ESSENTIALLY IT'S TAKING THE
MODEL OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC. WHERE THERE WAS
DECLARED ON A STATE LEVEL AND
THEN OF COURSE BACK THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP. WAS ABLE TO DO
THAT ON A FEDERAL LEVEL WHICH
DOES CREATE. A LOT MORE ACCESS
TO- JUST DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO AGAIN HELP. AND I KNOW THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S COME UP TODAY
IS THE PSYCHO EDUCATION AROUND
TRAUMA. AND ESPECIALLY THE CYCLE
EDUCATION AROUND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. SO BEING ABLE TO
DECLARE TATE OF EMERGENCY ON
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA I THINK WOULD
HELP. YOU KNOW THE MESSAGE
REALLY GET OUT THERE THAT IT'S
VERY PRETTY BASES. AND I CANNOT
LIVE A LOT OF THE WORK OUT OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT IS REALLY
PROGRESSIVE I THINK OUR FIRST
SPEAKER SURE ABOUT TODAY. YOU
KNOW THAT WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
GREAT WORK BEING DONE- BUT I
THINK THERE'S ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITY THERE THAT IF WE DID
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN OTHER
STATES. WOULD FOLLOW SUIT AND SO
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT. YOU KNOW
THE ASU STUDY. AND WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT CHILDHOOD ADVERSITY AND
HOW THAT SHOWS UP ON THE ADULT
SIDE OF LIFE- THERE'S A LOT OF
GREAT MOTIVATION AND REASONS WHY
WE WOULD WANT TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. WHETHER IT IS JUST TO
KIND OF INCREASE. THE AWARENESS
OF THE CYCLE EDUCATION. BUT ALSO
LIKE I SAID SURPRISE POTENTIALLY
ACCESS FUNDS SO THAT. WE CAN
CONNECT MORE FAMILIES TO THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED- SO
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID A
LOT OF THESE PREVENTATIVE
EFFORTS. WERE ABLE TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON BUT- THAT'S WHAT I
HAVE TO SHARE TODAY SO. THANK
YOU GUYS AGAIN FOR THE TIME.
AND- MY CONCERN IS VERY RICH
XING. TO HEAR FROM THE OTHER
PANEL IF. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TEST- ANY QUESTIONS FROM
OUR MEMBERS. SENATOR KIRBY ADAMS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M I'M
NOT A QUESTION I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT THAT- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS TESTIMONY THIS
IS THE HOPEFUL PART OF IT- I
WHAT I. EXPERIENCED AS DOING
CRIMINAL DEFENSE WORK- AND WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES OF- IS A
LOT OF TIMES IT'S REALLY HARD TO
FIGURE OUT. EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE FAMILY WITH THE
DYNAMICS ARE AND THERE WEREN'T
ANY INJURIES IT JUST PUSHING AND
EVERYBODY. ENDED UP GETTING
ARRESTED IN. AND I ALWAYS
RECOMMENDED THAT DURING THE TIME
THAT WE COULD DO IT- THAT IT MAY
BE- EVERYBODY BE DIVERTED AND
PUTTING IT INTO A PROGRAM
TOGETHER SO THAT THEY COULD
START WORKING OUT. WHATEVER THE
ISSUES WERE THEY THAT THEY HAD
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO BE
TOGETHER AND THEY CAME IN
TOGETHER AND THEY WOULD COME IN
TOGETHER AND SO THIS WHOLE IDEA
THAT THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE.
PEOPLE JUST NEED TO LEARN HOW TO
COMMUNICATE BETTER AND HOW TO-
HELP HAVE A GOOD EXPRESSED ITS
APPOINTMENT I MEAN IF THERE'S
ONE PLACE. THAT YOU'RE LIKELY TO
BE DISAPPOINTED MAD OR- FEELING
SAD IS AN EMERITUS AND OR IN A
RELATIONSHIP AND IF YOU CAN
LEARN HOW TO EXPRESS YOURSELF
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO
THESE. THESE KINDS OF THINGS
THESE PROGRAMS ARE REALLY- GIVE
ME HOPE THAT THERE'S- A WAY TO
BE ABLE TO HELP PROBABLY A
MAJORITY OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ARE- ARE EXPERIENCING THIS
KIND OF STRESS AND TO BE ABLE TO
LEARN HOW TO COMMUNICATE BETTER
. WITH THEMSELVES AND WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AS WELL. THIS IS HELP.
ME TODAY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU TO
REVIEW AND- THANK YOU- JONATHAN
FOR THAT TESTIMONY- WHAT WHAT I
WAS STRUCK BY IS JUST THAT. HOW
MUCH MORE WE'RE UNDERSTANDING
THAT. BOTH THE PERPETRATOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND THE VICTIM
THERE PAST TRAUMA CONTRIBUTED TO
THERE BEING IN THE CIRCUMSTANCE
THE RENT TO THE VICTIMS STAYING
IN THAT SITUATION BUT OF COURSE
THERE'S MANY OTHER COMPLICATED
FACTORS- BUT ALSO THE D. D.
PERPETRATOR BECAUSE THE
PERPETRATOR IT'S ENOUGH WHERE
IT'S ALL POWER DYNAMICS AND
IT'S- LIKE MAKING UP FOR A LACK
OF POWER THEY FEEL. THEY FEEL IN
THEIR OWN LIVES. AND THAT. WE
OUR CARCERAL SYSTEM WHETHER G.
OR PRISONS ARE IS REALLY STILL
NOT DESIGNED TO DEAL WITH TRAUMA
AND SO WHILE CLEARLY- WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW PENAL CODE STATUTES AND
SUCH DEAL THIS. IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GET AT THE
UNDERLYING NOW FOR SOME PEOPLE I
THINK IT ABSOLUTELY MUST BE
THERE. WITH THE CAR SERRATION IS
A NECESSARY HOWEVER FOR MANY IT
IT MAY JUST REALLY BE MORE THAT
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. AND IN
SOME CASES MAYBE NOT TOGETHER IN
OTHER CASES PERHAPS TOGETHER
MEETING WITH THE TWO PEOPLE OR
FOR THE WHOLE FAMILY. BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE IMPACT ON THE
CHILDREN IS MORE TRAUMA IN
TRAUMA THAT THEN CAN PLAY OUT
LATER IN THEIR LIVES SO. THE
MORE WE CAN FOCUS THIS WHERE
APPROPRIATE ON TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE THE BETTER AND YET WE ARE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE IN PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR SUCH CARE AND HAVE
STILL PRIMARILY RELIED ON THE
CARCERAL SYSTEM SO. AGAIN ANY OF
OUR PANELISTS SUGGESTIONS ON HOW
WE CAN DO THAT BETTER- CLEARLY
BUDGET IS ONE ISSUE BUT IT'S
THERE'S OTHER FACTORS. TOO WE
WELCOME THEM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT TWO THINGS WE WILL
CERTAINLY- THE MEMBERS OF THIS
PANEL EXPLORED THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY THAT YOU. ARE
SUGGESTED AND ALSO STRUCK ME I
MEAN I WAS A TEACHER AND I KNOW
WE'RE MANDATED REPORTERS. BUT
IT'S THE ASSUMPTION THAT WE ALL
KNOW WHAT TO LOOK FOR AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT TO REPORT SO I
THINK MAYBE EXPLORING SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES AND GUIDELINES FOR
THOSE MANDATED REPORTERS
CHAINMAIL AND BE ABLE TO REPORT
WHEN NEEDED SOMETIMES WE SEE
THINGS AND PERHAPS WE WILL NOT
RECOGNIZE IT IF WE'VE NEVER BEEN
IN A SITUATION. OR COME FROM A
HOME THAT'S NEVER SEEN VIOLENCE
SO VERY DIFFERENT SO THANK YOU
AGAIN- WE WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO
OUR SECOND PANELIST WE WILL HEAR
FROM. MS LABONTE SHE IS. WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
CHILD EMPOWERMENT AND SAFETY.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AND SPEAK TO YOU AND
ISN'T VERY IMPORTANT MEETING. I
AM ALSO REPRESENTING ANTS OUT
FORMERLY THE- FOUNDING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE STATE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE COALITION AND I THINK I
KNOW SOME OF YOU FROM THAT WORK-
I AM CURRENTLY WITH. A FIVE OH
ONE C. FOR ASUS FOR KIDS WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAD TO FORM
OF A NATIONAL COALITION OF
ADVOCATES TO ENSURE THAT CHILD
SAFETY IS A TOP PRIORITY IN
FAMILY COURT. BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN FIRST WITH THE STORY OF
CLEAR TEMP LOCAL. ON OCTOBER
TWENTY SECOND TWO THOUSAND CLEAR
ATTEMPT ON GOAL WAS BRUTALLY
MURDERED BY HER EX BOYFRIEND
TYREE RAMIREZ. RAMIREZ STABBED
CLEAR TO DEATH IN HER HOME IN
FRONT OF HER TWO YOUNG CHILDREN.
OUR TEN YEAR OLD SON. AND HER
FOUR YEAR OLD DAUGHTER. THIS WAS
ONE OF THE WORST DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENTS THAT SHOOK
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND THE
ENTIRE STATE. WHY BECAUSE
DESPITE OVER ONE HUNDRED LAWS IN
THE BOOKS ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ALL OUR SYSTEMS HAD
FAILED TO PROTECT CLAIRE AND HER
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. LIKE MOST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOMICIDES
CLEAR ATTEMPT ON GOAL DEATH WAS
COMPLETELY PREDICTABLE AND
PREVENTABLE FOR MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS SHE HAD COMPLETE
SHE HAD REPEATEDLY CALLED SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE TO REPORT
RAMIREZ'S VIOLENCE AND THREATS
AGAINST HER. AGAIN AND AGAIN SHE
TOLD OFFICERS OF THE ESCALATING
VIOLENCE HER FEARS FOR HERSELF
AND HER CHILDREN AND HER DESIRE
TO TALK TO YOU IN THE OFFICE BE
ARRESTED AND PROSECUTED. HOWEVER
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN CLEAR AGAIN
CALLED POLICE TO HER APARTMENT
REPORTING ROMEO ASSIST TERRORIST
THREATS AND TELLING THE
DISPATCHER THAT RAMIREZ HAD A
HISTORY OF VIOLENCE WITH HER AND
THAT SHE WAS SCARED HE WAS GOING
TO HURT HER CLEAR SHOW THE
OFFICERS THE EMERGENCY
PROTECTIVE ORDER FROM A
SEPTEMBER FIRST INCIDENT WHICH
HAD NOT BEEN SERVED. THE POLICE
FILED A QUOTE UNQUOTE TERRORIST
THREATS REPORT YET RAMIREZ WAS
ARRESTED AND BOOKED ONLY ON
PUBLIC INTOXICATION INTOXICATION
AND PROVIDING FALSE
IDENTIFICATION TO POLICE. THERE
WAS NO REFERENCE ON BOOKING
PAPER STORE EMERITUS THREATS OR
HIS HISTORY OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
. ONE MONTH BEFORE CLAIRE'S
MURDER RAMIREZ APPEARED IN COURT
FOR A REVOCATION OF PROBATION
HEARING ON THE OCTOBER NINETY
NINE CHARGE OF VIOLATING HIS
PROBATION BY DIPPING INTO A
PUBLIC RESTROOM. NO MENTION WAS
MADE OF THE PREVIOUS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENTS BY THE DA
ACCORDING TO JUDGE LILLIAN SING
. RAMIREZ ALREADY OUT ON
PROBATION WAS SENTENCED TO
THIRTY DAYS IN SHERIFF'S WORK
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM. IN ORDER TO
REPORT TO THE JAIL ON NOVEMBER
FIRST HOWEVER. THAT ON OCTOBER
TWENTY SECOND THAT WAS THE DAY
HE BRUTALLY STABBED CLAIRE
TEMPLE GO OVER SEVENTEEN TIMES
IN FRONT OF RITUAL VALUABLE
CHILDREN. I SHARE THAT STORY.
CAUSE OF DEATH ROW THE NICE THE
BAY AREA COMMUNITY AND ALSO
FEATURES SHOWED US WHY DESPITE
SOME OF OUR LAWS IN THE BOOKS
THINGS CONTINUED TO FAIL US. AND
WE WERE ASKED A DISPENSER CAN
PANEL TO SHARE HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN
VICTIMS AND FAMILIES. I THINK
THE VERY FIRST PROBLEM AND MANY
HAVE BEEN I'VE SPOKEN TO THIS
ALREADY BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
IT THAT CHILD VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. NOT ONLY S.
WITNESSES BUT DIRECTLY INJURED
ARE NOT PROTECTED IN FAMILY
COURT. NATIONAL RESEARCH BY
GERALDINE STALEY PHD FOUND THAT
OVER 85% OF CALIFORNIA MOTHERS
WHO CAME TO COURT. TO PROTECT
THEIR CHILDREN LOST PRIMARY
CUSTODY. THE IDENTIFIED ABUSIVE
PARENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
SOCIAL WORKERS MEDIATORS CUSTODY
EVALUATORS ATTORNEYS FOR THE
CHILDREN AND JUDGES MINIMIZED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE GIVING THE EXCUSE AND SOME
CONVICTED FATHERS UNSUPERVISED
ACCESS TO CHILDREN. THAT MUST
STOP 73% OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
REPORTED THAT THEY WERE RE
INJURED AND SOME HAVE BEEN
KILLED. THESE FINDINGS REPLICATE
OTHER NATIONAL STUDIES. ARMED
WITH CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE
PARENTS JUST- ON A NATIONAL A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION AND GOT A
CENTER FOR JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE
ALSO HAS A U. S. DIVORCE
HOMICIDE CHILD HOMICIDES THAT IS
ON THEIR WEBSITES. I THINK THE
SECOND ISSUE THAT I HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ALLUDED TO EARLIER BUT I
WANT TO GIVE CREDENCE TO SOME OF
THE TRAININGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE YEARS. IS
THAT THERE IS ANY NEED FOR
STANDARDIZED AND SPECIALIZED
TRAINING BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CHILD ABUSE SPECIALISTS FOR
ALL COURT OFFICIALS NOT JUST FOR
JUDGE THIS. THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
ON JUVENILE AND FAMILY COURT
JUDGES DOES AN AMAZING
CONFERENCE EVERY YEAR AND ALSO-
PROVIDES TRAININGS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE EXPERTS AND ADVOCATES
THAT ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER.
SO AT THE STATE LEVEL IF WE
COULD HAVE THOSE STANDARDIZED
TRAINING CONDUCTED. BY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND CHILD ABUSE
SPECIALIST FOR ALL COURT
OFFICIALS WOULD REALLY HELP. WE
WILL BE PRESENTING FEW TO
SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
WHICH I WON'T. GO INTO IT BUT
JUST BRIEFLY MENTION OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION IS BECAUSE OF THE
ISSUE THE ISSUE BEING VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE ENDANGERED
AND INTIMIDATED IN FAMILY
COURTS. VICTIMS ARE COERCED INTO
MEDIATING WITH ABUSERS FACE TO
FACE DESPITE RULE OF COURT FIVE
POINT TWO ONE FIVE. VICTIMS ARE
NOT GIVEN TIME TO LEAVE COURT
ROOMS BEFORE ABUSERS. EVEN WHEN
THEY HAVE A RESTRAINING ORDER.
VICTIMS ARE ORDERED TO MAKE
CUSTODY EXCHANGES WITHOUT
PROTECTION EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE A
RESTRAINING ORDER. OUR PROPOSED
SOLUTION IS TO AMEND PENAL CODE
SECTION TWO SIX FOUR POINT TWO
AND FINALLY COLD. SECTION THREE
ONE EIGHT ONE. THAT WILL BE
SUBMITTED TO YOU IN WRITING- BUT
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT OUR COALITION OF
ADVOCATES FIRST A PARTY'S
REQUEST FOR SEPARATE SESSIONS IS
NOT EVIDENCE OF HIS OR HER LACK
OF COOPERATION WITH THE PROCESS
WE WILL HIGHLIGHT THAT IN THE
LANGUAGE CHANGE THAT WE WILL
PROPOSE. SECOND IF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS DISCOVERED AFTER
MEDIATION ARE YOU VALUATION HAS
BEGUN THE PARTIES SHALL BE TOLD
SEPARATELY ABOUT SAFETY RELATED
ISSUES. AND THE OPTION OF
CONTINUING IN SEPARATE SESSIONS
AT SEPARATE TIMES THESE
INCREASING INCREASES SAFETY
FACTORS. THIRD THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF EACH PARTY
STEIN'S ARRIVAL DEPARTURE AND
MEETING SHALL BE PROTECTED. AND
FOURTH ANY PARTY WHO REQUESTED
SEPARATE MEDIATION SESSIONS DUE
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHALL BE
ASKED TO LEAVE THE COURT FIFTEEN
MINUTES BEFORE THE ACCUSED
OFFENDER IF THEY MUST APPEAR
TOGETHER IN PERSON FOR A HEARING
. OUR SECOND RECOMMENDATION WILL
POINT OUT TO A LEGISLATIVE FIX
IN EVIDENCE CODE SEVEN THIRTY.
WHEN FAMILIES HAVE RESOURCES.
FAMILY COURTS FREQUENTLY APPOINT
PRIVATE CUSTODY EVALUATORS UNDER
EVIDENCE CODE SEVEN THIRTY THE
COURT THE COURT RARELY PAYS FOR
THE EVALUATION EVEN THOUGH THE
APPOINTMENT IS FOR THE COURTS
NEEDS. THIS ADDRESSES WHAT
SENATOR COUPLE GYRO HAS THAT NOT
EVERY FAMILY ENTERS THE COURT IN
THE SAME WAY. PARENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY THE UNREGULATED
AND OFTEN COSTLY FEES DIRECTLY
TO WITH THE EVALUATOR. THE
PARENTS THEN WITH THE MOST
RESOURCES MAY PAY MORE OR ALL OF
THE FEES THEREBY RAISING
CONCERNS OF IMMEDIATE POSSIBLE
BIAS. THIS DOES NOT OCCUR IN
CRIMINAL AND JUVENILE COURTS.
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD ENSURE
THAT COMPENSATION FOR A PRIVATE
CUSTODY EVALUATION IS MADE BY
THE COURT NOT THE LITIGANTS SO
WE WILL PRESENT TO USE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE AMENDING CODES.
EVIDENCE CODE SEVEN THIRTY AND
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. I ADDITIONAL
STATE LEVEL- IDEAS THAT WE'D
LIKE TO PROPOSE IS THAT.
MEDIATORS AND EVALUATORS NEED TO
DO IN DANGER ASSESSMENTS FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEFENSE RYAN I
BELIEVE HIM I'M TALK ABOUT THIS
A LITTLE BIT HOW DO WE SCALE AND
REACH ASSESS THE LEVEL OF
DANGER. AND SO WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THOSE DANGER
ASSESSMENTS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS. AGAIN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS SHOULD NEVER
HAVE TO BE MEDIATE FACE TO FACE
WITH THEIR ABUSERS. OR LEAVE THE
COURT AT THE SAME TIME. AT LEAST
DANGEROUS AND INTIMIDATING
OUTCOMES HAPPEN FREQUENTLY IN
COURT. ALL FAMILY COURT
PROCEEDINGS HEARINGS NEED TO BE
RECORDED BY EITHER A COURT
REPORTER ARE ELECTRONICALLY MORE
AND MORE SOME COURTS ARE DOING
THIS IN DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THE ON THE COUNTY
OR THE STATE. ANOTHER IDEA IS-
ANY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM WHO
WAS SELF REPRESENTED WHILE THE
BATTER HAS AN ATTORNEY SHOULD
RECEIVE A PRO BONO ATTORNEY OR
HAVE AN ATTORNEY PAID BY THE
OTHER PARTY AS REQUIRED. AND
THEN A THIRD ANOTHER THING IS
THE RECENT LEGISLATION WHICH
THAT WAS A B. ELEVEN SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN BLANCA RUBIO-
REQUIRES A FORM FOR CORD
CONNECTED PROFESSIONALS TO
FOLLOW THE PROPER PROTOCOL FOR
INVESTIGATING CHILD ABUSE CASES
AND BRING FACTS AND EVIDENCE TO
THE COURT BUT MORE WORK IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THE FORM IS
PROPERLY UTILIZED. OUR ADVOCATES
HAD TRIED FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
TO GET A FORM TO IMPLEMENT
ANALLY CODE. THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN
IT TOOK THE HORRIBLE DEATH OF
LITTLE PC AND HIS MOTHER ANA
ESTEVEZ ADVOCACY AND
ASSEMBLYWOMAN RUBIO STRONG
ADVOCACY. BUT THIS THE COURT
STILL USE EVIDENCE CODE SEVEN
THIRTY EACH APPOINT EXPENSIVE
PSYCHOLOGIST TO DO MENTAL HEALTH
TESTING WHEN THERE ARE
ALLEGATIONS OF CHILD ABUSE
SPECIALLY CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE.
THIS NEVER TURNS OUT WELL FOR
ADULT AND CHILD VICTIMS BUT THE
COURT MAKES THE PARENTS STAYED
UP PROFESSIONAL DIRECTLY SO IT
ONLY APPLIES WHEN ONE PARENT HAS
LOTS OF RESOURCES. WE ARE ALSO
AWARE OF GENDER BIAS AGAINST
WOMEN IN COURTS MANY STUDIES
HAVE BEEN. DONE AROUND THAT.
THEY DO THIS INSTEAD OF
ORDERING- ORDERING AN
INVESTIGATION UNDER FAMILY CODE
THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN AND USING
THE EVIDENCE BASED PROTOCOL AND
YOU FORM. THE DEEPER ISSUES ARE
DEAF FRIENDLY PARENTS LOST THAT
LEAN THE CORD TOWARD SHARED
PARENTING DESPITE THE VIOLENCE
AND I THINK THIS IS WHERE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. ALL
THOSE WORKING IN THE COURTS IN
OUR LEGAL AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEMS ARE REALLY AWARE OF THAT
THE LEAST VALIDATE THE SITUATION
SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT BOTH THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR. AND
THE. THE CHILD OR CHILDREN. AT
THE LOK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- WE
WERE ALSO I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
PRESENT- WHAT CAN BE DONE. THE
COURT WATCH IT'S AN EXCELLENT
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE.
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
HAS DEVELOPED A METHOD USING
COLLEGE STUDENTS ESCORT WATCHERS
AGAIN I WILL SEND THAT TO YOU-
WHEN- WE COMPLETE THIS HEARING.
MULTI DISCIPLINARY INTERVIEW
CENTERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SOME
COUNTIES AND SOME NON PROFITS
ALREADY HAVE THE BEST. INTERVIEW
CENTERS FOR INTER BEING ALL
ABUSED CHILDREN ARE CRUCIAL.
GIVING COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES SERVICES TO CHILDREN
IN FAMILY COURT IN ADDITION TO
JUVENILE COURT WOULD BE A GREAT
HELP CASTEL WAS ALSO MENTIONED
EARLIER BY SENATOR COUPLE YET I
BELIEVE- AND MANY OF YOU ARE
AWARE OF FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS
WITH COLOCATED. SERVICES WHICH
TOGETHER WOULD GIVE VICTIMS A
ONE STOP SHOP FOR SERVICES SAN
DIEGO HAS A VERY NICE MODEL AS
WELL AS ALAMEDA COUNTY. I THEN
HAVING SPECIALIZED LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNITS TO INVESTIGATE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE. ACTUALLY IF THEY
CHARGE MULTIPLE CRIMES THEY NEED
TO BE THE LEAD AGENCY IN ALL
CRIME INVESTIGATIONS CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SOCIAL WORKERS
SHOULD NOT CALL. THE ACCUSED
BEFORE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERROGATION. ANOTHER LOCAL
APPROACH COULD BE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ADVOCATES SHOULD BE IN
THE COURTROOM AND PART OF THE
FAMILY COURT PROCESS TO ENSURE
VICTIMS ARE SUPPORTED AND THE
COURT DOES NOT MINIMIZE VIOLENCE
THEY WOULD BE THE ICING YOURS ON
BEHALF OF THE VICTIMS AND ALSO
WOULD SERVE THAT LEVEL OF-
TRAINING THAT THEY HAVE RECEIVED
AROUND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND I
THINK THIS WILL ADDRESS THAT THE
PROTECTING THE CHILDREN I EVEN
FURTHER IF A CHILD TWELVE OR
OLDER WISHES TO FILE A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST
APPEARANCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ADVOCATES COULD HELP IN THAT
PROCESS IN MANY OF THE SHELTERS-
WHICH WERE MEMBERS OF THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE COALITION BACK IN THE
DAY WHEN I. SERVICE ITS FOUNDING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ADVOCATES AT THE
SHELTERS WERE STILL STRAPPED
FINANCIALLY OFTEN AND THEY HAVE
TO ONLY FOCUS ON THE SURVIVORS.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FLED THEIR HOMES
BUT NOW THINGS ARE EASING UP AND
THAT WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE CHILDREN
TO HELP THEM ALSO FILED A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST THE
PARENTS. ON THIS AGAIN FURTHER
ADDRESSES SENATOR COUPLE YEARS.
EARLIER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ADVOCATES COULD HELP CHILDREN
PROVIDES THEIR WISHES FOR
CUSTODY AND VISITATION. ANY
VIEWS FOURTEEN OR OLDER WISH TO
TESTIFY DIRECTLY TO THE COURTS.
ADVOCATES COULD HELP THEM
REPAIR. ENSURE THEY DO NOT HAVE
TO TESTIFY IN OPEN COURT. AND
ASKED TO BE WITH THEM AS A
SUPPORT PERSON. THIS IS SOCCER
PRACTICE A BEST PRACTICE THAT WE
NEED TO START- MAKING SURE WE
IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
MR BOND OUT WE HAVE FILE ABOUT
ONE MORE MINUTE- THANK YOU. I
WILL BE ENDING SOON THE MYSTIC
VIOLENCE ADVOCATES WELL FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS NEED TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH EACH OTHER IN THE
FAMILY COURTS THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A BIT OF A SILO. AND
SEPARATION BETWEEN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND CHILD WELFARE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT IS NEEDS TO
COME TOGETHER AND THE FINAL
THING- TWO FINAL POINTS THAT I
WANT TO BRING UP IS THE FIVE THE
MAIN OTHER SOLUTIONS ON PRIMARY
PREVENTION- FOCUSING ON
PREVENTING FIRST TIME
PERPETRATION AND FIRST TIME
VICTIMIZATION. CALIFORNIA
ALREADY STARTED THIS THE.
CENTERS OF DISEASE CONTROL
CALLED DELTA. ARE YOUR AUDIO
WHEN OFF OUT DO YOU MIND PAUSING
FOR A SECOND. SORRY IF WE CAN
FOCUS ON THOSE CELLS PREVENTING
OR SOME PERPETRATION FIRST I'M
VICTIMIZATION AND REDUCING RISK
FACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND PROMOTING
PROTECTIVE FACTORS THAT REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE- AND THEN
FINALLY THIS IS ALREADY ONE OF
THE SUCCESSES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ORGANIZATIONS IS THE
COORDINATED COMMUNITY RESPONSES
OR CC ARE. ADDRESSING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THEY MUST BUT THEY
MUST INCLUDE MAKING CHILD SAFETY
A HIGHER PRIORITY. ON THE ISSUE
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
SAFETY IS NOT JUST AN
INTERSECTION TO ME IT'S NOT CO
OCCURRENCE BECAUSE THAT VIOLENCE
IS OCCURRING AND THEN BECOMES
PERPETRATED OVER TIME. AND WHILE
I'M AT IT I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO.
I WORKED NOW FORCED HEALING
CENTER IS THAT ARE BAD WHILE OUR
BATTER INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
HAVE COME A LONG WAY THERE'S
MUCH TO BE DONE TO GREAT- TO
MAKE SURE MOST PERPETRATORS-
HAVE. WE KNOW THAT MOST
PERPETRATORS HAVE BECOME- BEEN
VICTIMS THEMSELVES AS CHILDREN
HAVE NOT HEALED THE PROMISE OF
YOUR PAST OR OVERCOME THE
VIOLENCE LEARN FROM THEIR
FAMILIES THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT. THERE IS MUCH TO BE DONE
TO CREATE A MORAL CONFLICTS ON
AN INDIVIDUAL PRIOR TO
COMMITTING AN ACT OF VIOLENCE
THIS CAN ONLY BE ACHIEVED.
THROUGH A DEEPER LOOK AT ONCE
SPIRITUAL AND MORAL COMPASS. FOR
FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
AND COMMEND THE CODE COMMITTEE
FOR TACKLING THIS OFTEN
NEGLECTED AND FORGOTTEN CO
OCCURRENCE OF CHILD ABUSE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE US
POLICYMAKERS. WE AND OUR HAVE
BOTH THE PRIVILEGE AND POWER TO
INSTITUTE LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
FOR ASSISTANCE WITH FOR. REFORM
TO ENSURE SAFETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA HAS CREAM YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS- THE FUTURES
WITHOUT VIOLENCE THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY JONATHAN CENTERS
FOR JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE. PARENTS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COALITION THOSE STATE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ADVOCATES MUST
BE USED UTILIZED BY THE- STATE
LEGISLATURE US YOUR SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS THAT YOU CAN RELY
ON. TO BE ABLE TO. HELP CHANGE
LAWS ENACT NEW ONES AND MAKE
SURE THINGS ARE THOSE LAWS ARE
PROPERLY IMPLEMENTATION INSURE
SAFETY FOR BOTH CHILDREN. AND
WOMEN. VICTIMS THANK YOU. THE
YOU SO MUCH FOR TESTING AND ONE
RECOMMEND. CENTER SKINNER AND
QUESTIONS. THE TRAGEDIES THAT
YOU DESCRIBED ARE. BEYOND-
BEYOND COMPREHENSION THE WE KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY. THEY MAY NOT EVEN
HAD THE ARMS. OUR VARIOUS
MECHANISMS WORK IT'S POSSIBLE
AND WE'VE SEEN IT BEFORE. THAT
PERPETRATORS VIOLATE OD
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND SUCH
THOUGH CERTAINLY WHEN WE HAVE
TOOLS AND THEY ARE NOT USED IT
IS. YEAH IT IS WRONG AND THAT
WOMEN'S COMPLAINTS LIKE THIS ARE
NOT TAKEN SERIOUSLY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE KNOW AND WE HAVE SEEN
REPEATED AND HEARD DOCUMENTED
REPEATED CIRCUMSTANCES SO WE
NEED TO DO BETTER THERE BUT THEN
YOU HAD MANY OTHER CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PROVIDED TO US IN WRITING SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
AND WE OBVIOUSLY ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING ON DOING BETTER. AND
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU AND I SPOKE
ABOUT A CASE OF HONEST OF US WHO
LOST HER LITTLE BOY PICKY WAS
FIVE YEARS OLD- SHE'S FROM MY
CITY AND- AND A FRIEND AND IT
WAS UNFORTUNATE THAT SHE SPOKE
UP SO MANY TIMES AND NO ONE
WOULD LISTEN AND AT THE END SHE
LOST HER LITTLE BOY TO. TEAR HER
ABUSER- BECAUSE THE COURT FAILED
HERSELF THANK YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
HAVE YOU CAN EMAIL US WE WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THOSE POP ANDI
NEED TO APOLOGIZE A LOT TO THE
LAST PRESENTER WE DID HAVE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES AT THE
VERY BEGINNING SO I'M GOING TO
ASK EAST YOU MIGHT HEAR
TESTIMONY AS WE HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING AFTER THIS- SO
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME MRS
DUDLEY TAILORED THAT NEEDS. A
DIRECT THAT UCLA PROFESSOR
CENTER FOR STRENGTHENING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ARE.
WELCOME AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM.
HONORABLE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. LAST
YEAR WE COMMISSIONED A STUDY ON
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND CHILD WELFARE.
WHICH I WILL REVIEW SHORTLY.
TODAY GIVEN THE TIME CONSTRAINTS
I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OFF THE TOP
FRAME THIS DISCUSSION YOU'RE AN
EQUITY LENS. AS SENATOR CAFIERO
RAISED AND HIGHLIGHT HOW SOME
OTHER STATES ARE ALSO ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
QUICKLY SHARE SOME SLIDES THAT
WILL HELP ME. STAY ON TRACK ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AT UCLA WE
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR PRESENCE ON THE
TRADITIONAL ANCESTRAL AND
UNCEDED TERRITORY OF THE
GABRIELINO TONGVA PEOPLE. THE
UCLA PRITZKER CENTER IS A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY CENTER AT UCLA
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS. AND PREVENT
CHILDREN FROM ENTERING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AS THIS GROUP
KNOWS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FEEDS
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO A
LARGE EXTENT AND OUR QUESTION
HAS BEEN HOW TO MAKE IT STOP.
FOR THOSE CURRENTLY IN FOSTER
CARE BECAUSE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE'VE ASKED HOW
FAMILIES CAN BE REUNIFIED AND
SUPPORTED WITH PROPER SERVICES
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I'LL
PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE
STUDY THAT WE CONDUCTED WAGON
NOT NEXT CHILDREN COMPRISE THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AT AN
ALARMING AND DISPROPORTIONATE
RATE. THE CONFLUENCE OF POVERTY
AND RACIAL TRAUMA COMPOUND AND
MAKE THIS MORE LIKELY AND YET
UNACCEPTABLE. NEVER THE LESS WE
SEE CHILDREN REMOVED FROM THEIR
HOMES AND PLACED IN FOSTER CARE
FOR ISOLATED ALLEGATIONS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THIS CAN
RESULT IN FURTHER TRAUMA FOR
BOTH THE SURVIVOR AND THE
CHILDREN AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
AT LENGTH. OUR WORK EXAMINES
THIS DILEMMA AND THE IMPORT OF
CHILD SAFETY COUPLED WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF FAMILY SEPARATION
. I WORK WAS GENEROUSLY FUNDED
BY THE ANTI ENGINEER
TRANSCRIPTOMICS FOUNDATION THAT
I STRATEGIES AND THE BLUE SHIELD
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
WERE ALSO PLEASED TO THIS WORK
WITH A NUMBER OF PARTNERS ACROSS
LA COUNTY INCLUDING LA COUNTY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COUNCIL EASIER
FASTER. AND MANY TV AND HOW
WELFARE GROUPS. OUR RESEARCH
CONSISTED OF OVER FIFTY FOCUS
GROUPS AND INDIVIDUAL INTERVIEWS
THE SURVIVORS OF PARENTS AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH SOCIAL
WORKERS LAWYERS COMMUNITY
LEADERS JUDGES POLICYMAKERS. AND
PERPETRATORS WE ALSO CONDUCTED A
WRITTEN SURVEY THAT RECEIVED
OVER TWO HUNDRED RESPONSES.
AMONG THESE INDIVIDUALS WE SPOKE
WITH PRACTITIONERS IN OTHER
STATES INCLUDING NEW YORK
WASHINGTON NEBRASKA AND NEVADA.
THESE CONVERSATIONS INFORMED OUR
LEGAL RESEARCH AND THE
APPROACHES THAT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS TAKE TO ADDRESS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
WELFARE. AS PART OF THE LEGAL
RESEARCH WE ALSO COMPLETED A
FIFTY STATE SURVEY TO UNDERSTAND
HOW OTHER JURISDICTIONS ADDRESS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND FOSTER
CARE I'M PLEASED TO SHARE THAT
SURVEY WITH THIS HONORABLE
COMMITTEE. FOR ITS REVIEW. FOR
SOME CONTACTS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAS THE MOST CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE IN THE COUNTRY. AS OF
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY OVER HALF
NINETEEN THOUSAND OF THE THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE I'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. IF THIS ISSUE
THAT THIS BODY IS ADDRESSING TO
DIAPER MEANINGFULLY ADDRESSED
IMAGINE THE REDUCTION TO CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVED FAMILIES AND
HEALING THAT COULD OCCUR INSTEAD
. SHORTLY I WILL PRESENT A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. I WAS
GOING TO SHOW A VIDEO BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M GOING TO
SKIP IT. TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN
REMOVAL AND EXPOSURE TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE DIDN'T EXTENSIVE
LITERATURE REVIEW. WE LEARNED
THAT BOTH EXPERIENCES REMOVAL
FROM THE FAMILY AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONSTITUTE WHAT IS
KNOWN AS AN ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE. EXPOSURE TO ACES CAN
CAUSE IT'S WRONG OR TOXIC STRESS
RESPONSE YOU HAVE A LASTING.
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON HEALTH. NOT
JUST DURING CHILDHOOD BUT WELL
INTO ADULTHOOD. BECAUSE OF THAT
WE ARE ENCOURAGING THIS BODY AND
THE INVOLVED AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER THE BALANCE OF POWER
WHEN CONSIDERING REMOVAL BECAUSE
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I'D LIKE
TO START BY GOING ARE GOING OVER
OUR FIRST RECOMMENDATION
RELATING TO MANDATORY REPORTING
. MANDATORY RECORDING IS
SOMETHING THAT THIS AUDIENCE IS
FAMILIAR WITH BUT WHAT OUR
RESEARCH REVEALED IS THAT
BECAUSE OF MANDATORY REPORTING
AND SYSTEMIC RACISM AND OVERHAUL
IS REQUIRED WITH RESPECT HOW WE
SUPPORT AND SERVE. AS A FAMILY
DISCLOSES THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHEN TRYING TO GET HELP OR CARE
IT CAN LEAD TO DCFS INVOLVEMENT.
EVEN WHEN NOT SEEKING FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A FAMILY MAN
COUNTER SEVERAL MANDATED
REPORTERS THROUGHOUT THEIR DAILY
LIVES. FAMILIES OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN PARTICULAR
ENCOUNTER ENCOUNTER MANDATED
REPORTERS AT A GREATER RATE AND
ARE THE SUBJECT OF MORE RECORDS
THAN WHITE FAMILIES OR FAMILIES
WITH SOCIOECONOMIC MEANS. ANGEL
BY ALSO IMPACTS SOCIAL WORKERS
INVESTIGATION AND NEEDS MORE
FAMILIES OF COLOR ENSURING THE
SYSTEM. BECAUSE SURVIVORS MAY
FREQUENTLY INTERACTED MANDATED
REPORTERS THAN USUAL PRESSURED
TO HIDE THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THIS CONUNDRUM IS OFTEN WHAT
IMPACTS THE SURVIVORS LATER IN
THEIR DEPENDENCY CASE AND IS
USED AGAINST THEM TO DEMONSTRATE
THEIR FAILURE TO PROTECT. FOR
THIS REASON MANDATORY SUPPORTING
HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO MANDATORY
REPORTING. UNDER A MANDATORY
SUPPORTING PRACTICE WE CAN CALL
DCFS AND HOPE THAT IT DOESN'T
NEED TO INVESTIGATION AND
PROVIDE SERVICES INSTEAD. THE
CALL CAN ALSO BE MADE BUT IT
JUST CHANGES WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THAT CALL BY STEPPING BACK AND
ASKING OURSELVES DOES THIS
FAMILY SIMPLY NEED HELP. IT IS
THEREFORE RECOMMENDED THAT THIS
BODY CONSIDER REVIEWING
MANDATORY REPORTING LAWS AND HOW
THEY COMPOUND AND EXACERBATE
THIS ISSUE AND EVALUATE THE
POSSIBILITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
MANDATORY REPORTING. IN TERMS OF
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION
TRAINING ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
NEEDED FOR PROFESSIONALS
INVOLVED IN CHILD WELFARE I
UNDERSTAND THE POWER AND CONTROL
DYNAMICS AND THE TRAUMA
EXPERIENCED BY SURVIVORS. THE
CURRENT LACK OF TRAINING CAN
RESULT IN DECISION MAKERS
AUTHORITIES NOT BELIEVING
SURVIVORS NOT UNDERSTANDINGTHE
DYNAMICS OF POWER AND CONTROL
CAN LEAD TO A DECISION MAKER
BLAMING SURVIVORS FOR NOT
LEAVING A DV SITUATION AND I'M
WILLINGNESS OR AN INABILITY TO
RECOGNIZE PROTECTIVE PARENTING
CAPACITY WHICH IS A SURVIVOR
OFTEN DEMONSTRATES. IT IS
THEREFORE RECOMMENDED THAT THIS
BODY CONSIDER TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE ENERGY
ENTITIES WORKING WITH FAMILY
INCLUDING THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM AND THE COURTS WITH THE
TRAUMA INFORMED FOCUS AS
OUTLINED BY MR REX. IN TERMS OF
THE THIRD RECOMMENDATION IT
FOLLOWS THAT TRAINING AND A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WOULD LEND ITSELF TO
MORE NUANCED SERVICE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE LIKELIHOOD
OF REUNIFICATION AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM MORE NUANCED APPROACH
TO SERVICES SHOULD BE DEVELOPED
AND MORE TARGETED AND EFFECTIVE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE SHOULD
BE PROVIDED. THESE SERVICES
SHOULD ALSO BE PROVIDED TO
FAMILIES FOR FREE OF CHARGE AND
IN A CULTURALLY COMPETENT MANNER
. FURTHERMORE WHILE MANY
SERVICES ARE FUNDED PURSUANT TO
CONTRACTS WITH VARIOUS COUNTY
AGENCIES WE LEARNED AFTER
INTERVIEWING A NUMBER OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ORGANIZATIONS
THEY WERE NOT CONTRACTORS WITH
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM DESPITE
SERVICE DELIVERY. DCFS INVOLVED
FAMILIES THIS ARRANGEMENT SHOULD
BE EVALUATED TO ENSURE EQUITY
LINE SERVICE PROVIDERS
SUPPORTING DCFS FAMILY. AND
ADDRESS THE OFTEN HARSH
FINANCIAL REALITIES THAT SO MANY
TV ORGANIZATION SPACE. IS
THEREFORE RECOMMENDED THAT THIS
BODY CONSIDER HOW FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED AND DIRECTED AT THE
SERVICES AND ASSESS WHAT DEGREE
THE SERVICE THAT ACTUALLY HELP
FAMILIES AVOID. REMOVAL AND
PROMOTE REUNIFICATION. I KNOW I
LIKE TO TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT
SPECIALIZATION IS THE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITHIN CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEMS. WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDER A
SPECIALIZED SOCIAL WORKER OR A
NUMBER OF THEM THAT CAN ACTUALLY
ADDRESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HERE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M
PLEASED TO SHARE BUT IT APPEARS.
THE CSS IS NOW GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PRACTICE UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF SUPERVISOR
JOEL. WE'RE PARTICULARLY
INSPIRED BY SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES WHICH EMPLOYS A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SPECIALIST IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE RILEY
CENTER. AND OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE FORMER STAFF MEMBER IN
THIS ROLE WE LEARNED THAT THE
SPECIALIST HAS THE ABILITY TO
EIGHT SOCIAL WORKERS IN
DESIGNING SAFETY PLANS. AND
ASSIGN RELEVANT AND HELPFUL
SERVICES. MASSACHUSETTS HAS A
SIMILAR MODEL IN THEIR
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. IN MASSACHUSETTS THE
UNIT IS COMPRISED OF A NUMBER OF
SOCIAL WORKERS ALL THERE TO
SUPPORT AND ADDRESS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES. WITH RESPECT TO
THE COURTS OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION FOR
SPECIALIZATION IS TO IMPLEMENT A
SPECIALIZED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TRACK. THIS IS A PRACTICE AND A
BRASSICA THERE THEY HAVE
IMPLEMENTED ESPECIALLY
INDEPENDENT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEPENDENCY COURT WITH THE JUDGE
SOCIAL WORKERS AND LAWYERS WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCE AND EXTENSIVE
TRAINING IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IS THERE FOR RECOMMENDED THAT
THIS BODY CONSIDER THE
SPECIALIZATION NECESSARY WOULD
THEN STEAL BOTH WITHIN THE
COURTS AND IN CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY. AS SENATOR CAFIERO
POINTED OUT GUIDANCE FOR THE
COURTS IN THIS AREA IS THE
CENTRAL. LASTLY IN TERMS OF THE
STATUTORY CHANGE AS I MENTIONED
WE CONDUCTED A FIFTY STATE
SURVEY. LOOKING AT HOW EVERY
STATE IN THE NATION IS
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE. IN
WASHINGTON THAT'S HOW THE NEW
STATUTE EXPLICITLY STATES
POVERTY HOMELESSNESS OR EXPOSURE
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE NEGLIGENT TREATMENT
OR MALTREATMENT AND OF ITSELF.
ONE INTERVIEWEE FROM WASHINGTON
EMPHASIZED THAT DESPITE THE
STATUTORY TAX IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR SURVIVOR TO
UTILIZE THE STATUTORY PROVISION
. HOWEVER THESE ARE EXAMPLES OF
EFFORTS BEING MADE IN THE SPACE
THAT WE MAY LIKE TO CONSIDER
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. ADDITIONALLY
AS MR OKAMOTO OUTLINED EARLIER
J. STOCK CAN BE A STRONGER FORCE
OF LEGAL PROTECTION FOR FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IN NEW YORK THERE IS A GREAT
PRESIDENT UNDER THE KNUCKLES IN
CASE THAT RECOGNIZES THE HARM
THAT REMOVAL EVEN GRACE CAN COST
AND REQUIRES A COURT TO BALANCE
THE HARM OF REMOVAL BUT THE
HEART OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING. IS THERE
FOR RECOMMENDED THAT THIS BODY
CONSIDER LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WITH BOTH THE CHILD WELFARE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COMMUNITIES
IDEAS AND INSIGHTS IN MIND. WITH
THAT I'M PLEASED TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY BE HELPFUL TO
THIS BODY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WROTE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY ON THAT AND SORRY THAT
WE HAD TO RUSH YOU BACK TO A LOT
OF IMPORTANT TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
OFFERED A JOB SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND- PLEASE ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE YOUR POWER POINT
PRESENTATION SO WE CAN SHARE
WITH ALL. MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- AND SO- I WANT TO
THANK EVERY SINGLE PANELIST THAT
THAT SPOKE HERE TODAY AND I DO
WANT TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO-
THOSE ARE REMOTE A- PEOPLE
CALLING IN TO TESTIFY. SO I
WOULD LIKE TO CHECK IN. WITH
SENATOR SKINNER IF THERE IS ANY
LAST QUESTIONS ARE COMMON FOR A
PANELIST BEFORE WE MOVE ON. TO-
THOSE CALLING IN. I'M JUST
APPRECIATE- THE- COMMENTS BY MR
ITALY AND- GLAD THAT WE ARE
GOING TO GET THAT IN WRITING.
AND THEN I THINK I WILL REFRAIN
FROM I COULD SAY MORE BUT WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT AND I WILL
HAVE TO LEAVE VERY SOON. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- SO AGAIN THANK YOU
TO ALL THE PANELISTS AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIR MAY
INSTITUTE LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
AND I WILL DECIDE THAT IF ONCE
WE KNOW HOW MANY CALLERS WE HAVE
. NOW LET'S BEGIN I WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO ROME FORTY TWO OR THREE
IF THERE IS ANY WITNESSES. C.
NINE WE WILL NOW GO TO TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK.
C. NINE I THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
BE A HEARING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
OPERATOR CAN YOU SHARE HOW MANY
COLORS WE HAVE. AT THIS TIME WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- SO I WILL
LET THEM SENATOR SKINNER WRAP UP
CLOSING COMMENTS BEFORE WE CLOSE
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR SKINNER-
THANK YOU TO REVIEW- SO THERE IS
A OT OF RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
AND WE ARE A BIG STATE. AND THE
JUST THE- TAKE LA COUNTY IS HAS
BEEN ALREADY INTO SOME OF THE
DATA PRESENTED ALREADY THAT WE
HAVE. THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
CHILDREN IN FOSTER. ANY OF
ANYWHERE IN THE WHOLE U. S. AND
A GOOD PERCENT OF THOSE KIDS
WERE- SUBJECT TO- WE'RE IN
HOUSEHOLDS WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND WE- WE KNOW THAT
IN THAT THAT'S THE CASE AND- YOU
KNOW MANY OF MOST OTHER
EVERYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE. SO
THE QUESTION OF HOW WE IN IN
CALIFORNIA IS VERY ORIENTED.
TOWARDS COUNTY- COUNTY SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS IN ALL THESE AREAS OUR
IT'S OUR COUNTY OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE COUNTY WORKERS OUR
COURTS ARE IN EFFECT COUNTY
COURTS AND EVEN THOUGH WE SET
STATEWIDE POLICY IT'S VERY MUCH
UP TO THE COUNTIES TO DELIVER
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE IT IS
COMPLETELY AVAILABLE TO ANY
COUNTY TO SET UP THE TYPE OF
PROGRAM LIKE IN NEBRASKA WHERE
THEY HAVE A DEPENDENCY COURT%
WHERE THEY UTILIZED THE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND- THE- CHART YOU KNOW
INTEGRATE ALL ALL OF THE-
SYSTEMS AND MAKE A VERY FOCUSED
ON DEMAND. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IT
IS AVAILABLE NOT ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT
WHETHER WE HAVE TO PROVIDE SOME
MORE INCENTIVE OR I THINK THOSE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER AND- AND OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. FOR BOTH
PERPETRATORS AND- AND VICTIMS
BUT OF COURSE ESPECIALLY THE
VICTIMS AND THEIR CHILDREN TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE VICTIMS AND
THE CHILDREN ARE NOT PUNISHED
FOR BEING IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE
BUT I THINK THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- D. D.
CARCERAL ASPECT ALONE WILL NOT
SOLVE THIS SO I REALLY I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE TESTIMONY AND
I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO IT TOO
LOOKING AT. THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN DETAIL WITH MY STAFF AND THEN
COLLABORATING WITH THEIR ARCHER
. THANK YOU SENATOR SCANNER AND
I KNOW HOW- WE'VE WORKED SO WELL
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS ISSUE SO I
GOT WHAT I WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I'LL
CONTINUE TO- TO WORK WITH YOU I
KNOW WE HEARD SO MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN. A LOT OF
I. OPENING CASES THAT WERE
SHARED- AND I THINK THAT- THE
OVER ARCHING I WOULD SEE THEME
IS EDUCATION AND IMPLEMENTATION
AND MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE'S
ON THE SAME PAGE- AS SENATOR
SKINNER SURE THERE'S A LOT OF.
THINGS THAT COUNTIES COULD
ALREADY DO IT'S JUST FIGURING
OUT WHAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT
THEM TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS. OR EDUCATION HAPPENS
BUT I DO WANT TO POINT OUT TWO
THINGS- I KNOW ONE OF THE-
PRESENTERS- DISCUSSED. MAYBE
SEPARATING THE VICTIM WITH THE
PERPETRATOR OR COMING AT
DIFFERENT TIMES OUT SO BUT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A BILL THAT I
PASS THIS LAST YEAR SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL ALLOW
VICTIMS NOW TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
REMOTELY- YOU KNOW FOURTEEN THE
COURT NEEDED SOME TIME TO
IMPLEMENT AND SO IT WILL BECOME.
A LAW TWEET TWENTY THREE YES
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND SO THAT
WILL HELP WITH- THE INTIMIDATION
AND OTHER ITEMS RECOUNTING THEIR
STORIES FOR FEAR OF BEING A FUN
OTHER ABUSE YOURSELFHOPEFULLY
IT'S ONE STEP CLOSER TO. TO
MAKING SURE THAT VICTIMS FEEL
CONFIDENT AND COMFORTABLE- YOU
KNOW SPEAKING THEIR TRUTH AND
TELLING THEIR STORIES- WE ALSO
HEARD SOME CHALLENGES WITH- I'M
ON MY BILL SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE
WHICH ADDRESSES COURSE OF
CONTROL A LOT MORE WORK TO BE
DONE IN THAT SPACE AND- AND
AGAIN IT'S UNDERSTANDING- BY THE
COURTS AND A PUBLIC SAFETY AND
OTHERS UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT IS
AND HOW WE CAN HELP ENFORCE IT
AND- WHETHER WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. OR FIND DEAN OR
ANYTHING TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT-
THAT IT'S BEING UTILIZED
CORRECTLY- BUT LASTLY I WILL
FINISH WITH THIS YOU KNOW WE HAD
SOME GREAT TESTIMONY FROM ALL
PANELISTS IN WHAT I. TOOK AWAY
FROM IT IS YOU KNOW- DO HAVE SO
MANY LAWS THAT FOLK ON PROTECT
VICTIM BUT I- YOU KNOW ALSO-
REALLY ENCOURAGED BY WHAT I
HEARD BY ONE OF THE PANELISTS
AND I GUESS IT'S TRYING TO BRING
THAT BALANCE BETWEEN. LEAVING A
CHILD IN A VICTIM IN A HOME
WHERE THERE IS ABUSE. OB BUT
THAT BALANCE OF WHAT MR. OKAMOTO
SHARED AND THAT HE IS SOMETIMES
THERE IS THAT THIS OVER REACTION
THAT AUTOMATICALLY BREAKS UP
FAMILIES- WHEN SOMETHING CAN BE
DONE IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
SERVICES AND COUNSELING IN
KEEPING THE FAMILY UNIT TOGETHER
WHICH MAY BE. WHAT'S BEST FOR
THAT FAMILY CELL AGAIN TRYING TO
BRING THAT BALANCE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER GOT A GENERAL AND
ALL OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
WHETHER IT'S THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE TO ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH ON THESE
ISSUES. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS HERE-
TESTIMONY IS VALUABLE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU TAKE TO
BE HERE AND ANYONE LISTENING AT
HOME THANK YOU FOR. FOR
LISTENING- BUT IT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ALL THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THAT ALL OUR
MEMBERS HERE HALF OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE WILL.
CONVENE IN A FUTURE UPDATE SO WE
CAN EXPLORE HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE AND THE
COMMITTEE IS NOW. IN RECESS
THANK YOU. THANKS EVERYBODY
TAYLOR YOU WERE AWESOME I WANT
TO MEET YOU I MEAN LA. OKAY
GREAT I'D LOVE TO HEAR THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE CONNECT VIA EMAIL I.